Oh Shit,
we're back.
That's right.
The full charges as gentlemen,
what's up y'all charge is live with Joe
Rogan experience.
Yes.
This episode is brought to you by one
800 flowers.com
and 100.
One 800 flowers.com.
Has An awesome limited time Christmas
offer,
a one dozen red roses and you get
another dozen free.
Oh Shit.
Red Roses today.
That's a strong power move.
Like two dozen red roses.
That's like telling someone that you're
really into.
I know your last man gave you a dozen
baby.
I'm coming to.
They're coming in fresh,
slightly chilled.
Two dozen red roses for just 29,
$99.
$20 off the original price.
That's pretty sweet.
It makes you look like a bar and it's
actually not that much money.
Twenty $9.
Ninety nine to live like a bar,
like two dozen red roses like that's
Kapow.
That's you're showing massive amounts of
affection.
There's going to be wet panties after
that.
Instantly.
Full charge predicts.
Wet panties with Japan is.
Well,
that's because you're the one who's been
given them them flowers,
right?
They know it's coming from the full
charge.
Two dozen double pistol,
Bam,
paying two dozen red roses for just 29,
99.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you could just buy them and take them to
a bar and make some extra cash.
Be Annoying.
Fucking annoying is that man.
If you're a day now for the navy,
come on.
That's such a cheap movie,
but that's.
Think of how much money you wanted to
buy a flower.
I would be at a flower store.
Okay.
I'm not sitting in a restaurant and
someone comes up and tries to sell me
bike tires.
All right?
If I want a flower,
I'd be at a place that fucking sells
flowers.
Not on a special date at a restaurant,
not trained to buy flowers,
bitch.
The next level is bringing a bag of
oranges up to the table.
An off ramp back.
What'd you guys do?
Like to buy gum?
Maybe that's the next pressure.
Move.
Takes your breath.
Stinks.
Perhaps some gum gums.
I said Elca pottery last night and they
were trying to.
This woman comes up and goes,
would you like a complimentary postcard
photo?
And I'm like,
no.
And then I heard the person next to me
goes,
oh,
it's complimentary.
She goes,
well it costs $10 for me to take the
photo.
That so slick.
If you're doing shit like that,
your product sucks.
A fat one,
not like stamps.com.
Not like,
not like ting,
not like audible.
Now like one 800 flowers.com.
Not like our bad ass sponsors.
One 800 flowers.com.
That's two dozen red roses.
Just 29 99.
And that's $20 off the original price.
But this is only available today today.
Like don't just do it.
Pitch,
get on that shit.
Scared.
There's a radio list.
Day One dozen red roses.
Get another dozen free available only
today.
Go to one 800 flowers.com
from your desktop or mobile device.
Click on the radio microphone in the
upper right hand corner and enter J R,
e dot.
That's the code for this show.
That's one 800 flowers.com.
And enter jre or call one 800 flowers.
And mentioned jre.
I would.
I like calling people,
man.
I'm fucking.
I'm not ordering things online anymore.
I'm done.
I need to speak to humans.
There's a disconnect.
Yeah,
right.
I hear target just got hacked.
Really heard it on the news that said
like if you've ever shopped at target or
online,
no,
you're fucked.
You're going to credit card.
That is everybody we need is everybody
just everything's going through
computers.
It's just numbers and fucking data.
It's nice to talk to a person every now
and then,
especially if they live in America.
It's really disconcerting.
It feels strange.
Not there's anything wrong with talking
to people from India and most certainly
is nothing wrong with talking to people
from India,
but when you're on the phone with
someone,
you know they're not even in America.
It's a head trip.
It's like what Dell?
What did you do?
Why?
Whatever companies do it.
Like what?
What are you doing?
Why is he these people on the other side
of the world in a sweat factory phone
answering.
It makes you feel like the company
doesn't care about any of us.
At the end it feels like you're being
put off,
but you gotta think like how many
knucklehead fucking phone calls if you
are running a computer company,
say if you're selling windows computers
and you've got a customer service line,
just stop and think about the fucking
numb skull questions your friends have
asked you about their computers.
Like you know that one friend that
didn't get a laptop until he was 30.
Alright,
alright.
I'm getting in and starts asking
questions.
She had something wrong with my video
drive.
Like,
oh,
there's something wrong with your video
drive.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
How fucking what?
Where were you living when you live in
it?
You didn't understand the computer.
What's cut and paste?
What am I supposed to do that with
gateway?
Man,
it was the worst.
Yeah,
you did that.
So what I'm,
what I was thinking is that that job is,
you know,
that's like nobody wants that.
That's the reason why they pawn it off
after a.
they'd probably fuck it.
We can,
we can't do this.
This is ridiculous.
We can't really give advice.
He gives good advice.
These motherfuckers will never get off
the phone,
they can't figure out anything.
They don't know too much.
I got to come to your house.
I'm going to sit down with you for hours
on end.
You have to be interested in learning.
Yeah,
that's the tough part.
If you're starting from scratch now,
you know,
fucking too much,
man.
We've adapted all of our skills and
searching,
clicking and pasting and control,
seeing and control all the leading and
we,
we've,
we've been fucking hitting keyboards for
so long when someone's never done it and
they're like looking for the why and
like,
oh,
I'll come back tomorrow.
There's a new pop
machines that they have where you can
choose all the different flavors.
Like coke,
coke,
orange.
I was behind an old couple of last night
at Boston market and it took them like
10 minutes.
Just a poor cocacola.
Well there used to places where they
actually are the options.
They're from a generation where they
ordered a coke and then someone brought
it to them.
Well,
you didn't have to work at the
restaurant
as well.
Made the coke at the place.
We'll just get through these sponsors
real quick.
Um,
we're also brought to you by ting.
If you go to [inaudible] dot ting.com,
if you never heard of ting.
Ting is,
uh,
one of our favorite sponsors because
it's the only one that we have other
than squarespace.
And I think I've never heard anybody say
a single negative thing about it.
Everybody who's used it loves it.
Guys that are on the podcast regularly,
like Chris Ryan,
he used it,
says it saved them money.
They say that 98 percent of people would
save money with Ting and that's what it
says on their website because they do
mobile differently and what they mean by
that is that,
first of all,
they don't have contracts.
You don't have to be connected with them
in a way that it makes it really
uncomfortable to get out of it.
What they have is real straightforward,
no nonsense cellular service.
It's available on the sprint network.
They buy time on the sprint backbone.
So you're dealing with a really high end
cell phone signal.
You're dealing with four G,
you're dealing with the top Nokia
devices that top Samsung devices,
all the bad ass android devices on the
big screen.
Once that's what they sell and you can
bring them over from,
um,
from a sprint as well.
Uh,
if you,
if you have phones for sprints,
particularly even iphones for the
forecast,
you can bring them over from sprint.
What,
what they're trying to do is give you a
no bullshit cell phone service where
they don't have to rip you off.
They charge you a decent rate for an
excellent service and everybody's happy.
It's just an ethical way to do business.
It's a,
it's an interesting approach and we've
had nothing but positive feedback from
the people that have used it.
I don't know,
Brian saved $100 or something when he
was in.
What was it?
I save $100 every month using my team,
my,
my bill last month and I've been since I
got this galaxy note three,
I've been using it like crazy.
And My bill last month was 27 bucks.
You can buy six dozen roses with the
fucking sell it.
Sell it,
flipped them roses.
Yeah.
Thing.
It's confusing.
Ting
has the phone that I'm using right now,
which was the Samsung Galaxy note three.
It's fucking amazing.
I'm so into this phone.
I've never had a better phone for doing
everything that.
Yeah,
it's just so big that it just makes me,
uh,
makes me like,
look like iphones will play toys now.
It's such a rich experience.
Like,
you know,
like if you go to a website,
you almost get a real website.
It's like you're moving it
around.
Shit fits in my back pocket.
Tim has that.
They also have the galaxy s four,
which is a,
another really pretty dope,
a Samsung phone.
They have all the best of the um,
what is off the sprint network?
All the best phones that uh,
you could get like,
um,
it was the nexus to.
What was it?
There's a bunch of nexuses galaxy mega
black also.
They have to admit that that megaphone,
which is even bigger than it note,
or they have that crazy thing.
Yeah,
they have,
I think it's bigger.
I,
you know what else I have?
I have that htc one that is also another
excellent phone.
That phone is beautiful too.
Like the build quality.
It's all aluminum.
It's pretty sleek.
That's that one on the far right.
That's bad ass.
Nice.
That's probably the right side.
I always say that people like,
my phone's probably too big like three
months from now,
but like what am I doing?
This big fucking stupid thing on my
ipad.
I'm starting to not like this flap as
much.
Like the slabs.
Annoying.
Yeah.
Because I don't like the book.
I think I'm going to go back to a
regular case.
Yeah,
me too.
Because it seems like you have to hold
it weird.
It doesn't feel like it can grip it or
what do you got?
You've got a mirror in the.
In the flap.
Dan.
Handsome.
I keep.
Keep my powder.
Open it up.
Imagine there's like a little lip balm.
Their little thing you unscrew.
Um,
at first I thought it was really cool
and now it's annoying.
Yeah,
it just doesn't feel good on the hand.
It's,
well,
it's goofy for.
You're trying to.
If you're trying to do anything with one
hand,
I feel like you have to spin it around
and hold it in place and I guess it's
not that bad.
Not too bad.
Maybe I'll miss it when it's gone,
but for now get all depressed.
Go to Rogan.ting.com.
And you can save 25 bucks off of any of
their new phones that they sell.
And as we said,
they're all the top of the line.
Android phones,
the ones that uh,
I'm actually using right now.
So we'll go there.
Get yourself some fucking roses.
I wouldn't give it that nice one and
read that one that you have been in red.
Oh,
the htc one is awesome phone.
I'm Brogan Dot Ting.com.
Go there.
My friends go fly.
Be Free and enjoy cheap cell phone
service from an excellent provider.
Uh,
I shouldn't say cheap.
Inexpensive people.
Don't like cheap.
An expensive.
Learn that Phil charge.
This is called advertising lingo.
I'm trying to school you sign.
It's a bargain.
It ain't cheap.
It's a fucking bargain.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com on it is o n n I t,
and if you've paid attention to,
uh,
some of the more recent things about
vitamins a,
there's a,
a fascinating blog that aubrey put up
over it on it.
Vitamins.
There's all this debate about whether or
not these new studies showed vitamins to
be,
uh,
to be dangerous or have to be
ineffective.
And the study is actually a really
pretty limited.
I was kind of shocked that they would
make the conclusions from this study
that they made because what the study
showed was first of all,
people who had already had heart disease
and these are very minimal doses of
synthetic vitamins too.
And they showed people with a heart
heart that had already had heart
attacks,
like recovery from heart attacks.
People showing a cognitive decline.
And I forget there was one other one,
but the idea behind it was that they
were showing that vitamins we're just
not effective.
And that because in these three cases
that they're stating that they didn't
show in a positive impact using what are
essentially synthetic vitamins.
The best way to get vitamins for sure is
from food,
but if you want to get high level
nutrients like really high levels in
your body to the point where it's
affecting you in positive ways,
like with a nootropic or with a vitamin
B,
12,
when you're exercising to actually get
that all from food.
Holy Fuck Shit.
A lot of weird shit.
A lot of planning.
Yeah.
This.
The idea that these vitamins don't work
is silly.
There's a reason why everyone knows by
vitamin 12 gives you energy.
It's because it's universally accepted.
If you take a shot of vitamin B 12,
if they give it to you inter muscularly,
it has an impact on your energy.
There's no doubt about it.
When you work out,
you feel like you have more,
more energy,
more Gusto.
You have more vibrance to it.
Fucking make it mean.
That's a pretty important discovery that
a vitamin gives your body more energy to
push hard,
but it does.
It really does work like B.
Twelve is about as rock.
Solid science is against.
These are the reason why these things
have all been isolated,
like they know what the effects of these
things are and there's a gang of studies
that showed a different improvements and
people that had taken vitamins for
infectious illness,
for mood and stress,
cognition,
work,
stress.
They even did a study on juvenile
delinquency and they showed an
improvement in juvenile delinquency.
Yeah,
and the lack of it.
If you give the kids healthy vitamins,
well,
I read something in that that most of
the people that commit suicide are
vitamin deficient and I don't know if
vitamins can help you with that,
but while it says something right there,
I mean it makes you really unhappy if
you don't have all your vitamins.
There's no doubt.
I think a lot of people with the average
American diet are vitamin deficient and
it's way better,
way better to get your diet in order and
then slept.
It's way better,
but I don't think there's ever any wrong
reason to supplement as long as you're
getting good vitamins and nutrients and
that's where it gets weird because all
vitamins are not created equal.
So when he makes like an irresponsible
statement where you like case closed,
vitamins don't work,
that's really silly because you're your
actual studies.
They didn't prove that at all.
In fact,
it does work.
There's a reason why they know that,
that scurvy is cured by vitamin C.
it's a vitamin C deficiency.
We have isolated all of these compounds
that are crucial to human health.
They know what the fuck they are.
Doesn't.
If the FDA loved to say vitamins don't
work,
I don't know who's saying it.
I think it's just these doctors that
are,
uh,
that,
that put together a case,
um,
with these,
uh,
multivitamin researchers.
But it's,
look,
they've got us talking about it,
you know,
it's,
it's certainly something to be discussed
because I think they're right writing a
lot of ways and what they're right in a
lot of ways is that if you take like a
standard multivitamin and you don't know
the source of it,
you don't know if it's food base.
You don't know if it's plant based,
you don't know where they are.
Extracting their nutrients from you,
you're very likely to get.
Doesn't absorb.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
it it most certainly doesn't absorb as
well as the food,
but you're,
you're.
You don't know what levels you're
getting.
Like you don't know.
You don't know where,
where they're extracting it from,
how much bile availability is in these
vitamins.
All vitamins are not created equally and
the way you break them down is not
created equal either.
Like those,
those one a day things will have blue
tablets.
They famously find those fucking things
in the bottom of those Porta potties and
people shut them out and they see this
little blue bullets.
I've read it online,
so it must be true.
I've done no research,
no research port-a-potty research on my
own.
That might be a snitch thing is,
is that what these people are saying?
Are there or are they saying that normal
multivitamin,
you don't absorb any enough to do
anything?
Is that what they're claiming they're
claiming is that they've shown that
vitamins?
Well,
they're basically saying that vitamins
are not worth your time,
that vitamins,
the vitamins don't work enough is
enough.
Stop wasting your money on vitamin and
mineral supplements is the actual title
of the piece.
They found that most people that use
Porta potties have diarrhea.
Well that that's crazy.
It's say it's out of there quick little
raft ride.
You also don't use it unless it's an
emergency.
It's like a log roll down a raft.
Everything out,
everything out of raging river.
I take [inaudible] every morning under
my tongue and I immediately feel it will
be 12 is also proven effective.
It's a joke to say the vitamins and
minerals don't do anything for your body
as a silly statement,
so when you see this enough is enough.
Stop wasting money on vitamin and
mineral supplements and then you look at
their actual findings.
The findings were like there was a very
limited test done on a.
They were male physicians over 65 showed
no improvement in cognitive decline
using generic multivitamins
supplementation.
Okay?
That's one.
It's male physicians over age 65.
Okay,
alright.
They still went nutty.
They had a cognitive decline.
Okay,
and they showed no improvement in
cognitive decline using generic
multivitamins.
Supplements.
So fucking what?
That doesn't mean anything like generic
multivitamins,
supplements,
and you're talking about guys who are
over age 65 that are already sliding
into the abyss.
You saying vitamins didn't haul them
from what nature?
Vitamins didn't hold them from the old
process because that's what you're
talking about here.
So that's one part of this study.
Another study showed that high dose
multivitamins had no effect on the
progression of heart disease and heart
attacks of virus.
Okay?
Now you're talking about people who had
fucking heart attack and then you give
them multivitamins and you're.
You're saying that vitamins didn't hell,
how the fuck do you know that it didn't
have an effect on progression of heart
disease?
How the fuck do you know that they
wouldn't have already gotten even
quicker,
a relapse of a heart attack if they
weren't taking vitamins like the
person's dying already had a heart
attack.
If you have one heart attack,
you're.
You're very likely to have another.
So saying that multivitamins don't work
because it didn't stop that.
This is crazy talk.
You're talking about people that are
already dying.
It just seems very irresponsible.
It's very irresponsible.
It's irresponsible and very suspect.
It doesn't make any sense and I should
point out that it on it.
We don't sell multivitamins,
we don't sell any of that shit.
We sell only food based stuff because
the closer it is to food,
the easier it is for your body to digest
it.
It's just really simple stuff.
With synthetic stuff can work,
but it doesn't work as good for your
body.
Like it's not as bioavailable as what
you can extract from food and that's why
when we sell vitamins we try to sell
like like supplements.
If it's green stuff,
it's like spirulina and chlorella.
That's how you say it.
I don't know one ever say it.
I just read it and then green
supplements.
There's way better to get it in food
though.
And what is this?
Just like dehydrated food or what?
Well,
I don't know how they extracted the
extract is probably probably says it on
the website somewhere,
but it's essentially they're extracting
nutrients from from Greens and grass and
things along those lines and you just
mix this shit in water and you get a
better nutritional response than just a
cheeseburger.
And fries that ain't doing anything.
It's.
It'll be better for you than a lot of
things.
It's just a supplement and having
supplements,
it allows us in our busy everyday life
too.
You know,
you can,
you can boost your body's performance,
you can give yourself a little bit of an
edge and a lot of different areas.
Whether it's workouts to taking
something like shroom tech sport which
is based out of the quarter steps
mushroom.
It's been proven that the quarter
mushroom has a really positive effect on
your body's ability to process oxygen.
And it's really interesting stuff
because they first learned about it from
high altitude hurting populations and
apparently what had happened was their
cows would eat these mushrooms is
quarter eps mushrooms and they,
they became more active and they were
noticing that they're more mobile.
Well,
they're living,
they're more active than moving around
more and they,
they pieced it together and figured out
that this is a mushroom that they were
eating and when they were eating this
mushroom,
that's when they started having this
response.
So that also is mixed with a very
bioavailable form of vitamin B 12 and
it's an awesome supplement to take about
an hour before you work out all these
things work and we're so confident that
they work that we have a 90 day 30 pill
moneyback guarantee when you buy new
mood,
which is a five htp supplement,
um,
which is designed to give your body the
building blocks for Serotonin,
give your body the building blocks to
make your brain actually feel better
when all this stuff is fascinating
stuff.
And there's a lot of science behind five
htp as well,
and all the other different supplements.
It's all listed on it.
Go to o,
n n I t this commercials too long and
entering the code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
All right,
boom.
The full charges here,
gentlemen,
let's get freaky.
Yes.
Keith.dot
podcast.
The full chart.
By the way,
I have spoken to the actual Nick Diaz
himself,
the man in the train by day video.
Yeah.
And he,
he's going to do the podcast,
allegedly nick.
He's,
he's a,
he's a free spirit.
He might change his mind.
Right,
right,
right.
Like you're free.
You're free spirit.
A Duncan trussell budding.
Yeah.
Well,
no.
Duncan had a very legitimate reason.
One hundred percent legitimate reason
that he couldn't podcast today.
That's all good.
No,
no,
but it's a personal reason and he'll be
on Tuesday.
People used to mistake us for one
another back in the day because I never
have,
you know,
what is it?
The glasses?
I think it was the nose and we both got
big teeth.
When I saw him,
I'm like,
that's my brother from another mother.
Really?
I mean,
you get older,
you start to look different.
It's not the same thing anymore,
but when I met him when we were both
younger and someone has called me a
Duncan trussell looking motherfucker.
That's a quote.
That was the guy that knew you were a
comic.
Yeah,
this was fat jams.
I don't know if you knew that Jay
course.
I knew James.
I was very sad when he passed.
I miss that guy.
He was a sweetheart.
Yeah.
Fat James for the comedy store and he
called himself Pat James Folks.
Sure.
He put his hand out and say,
fat James.
Hi James.
Pleased to meet you.
He would literally call himself James.
He was a fun guy to be around.
That was his hook.
I'm fat.
Fat.
James's story was he came home one
night.
He was fit.
I guess he was in the military,
right?
Wasn't he in the military?
I didn't know him that well.
He wasn't he in the military?
Do you know Brian?
I don't remember that part.
Was either a cop or he's in the
military.
One of those.
Anyway,
he was fit.
He was like healthy guy.
He came home and caught his wife and his
best friend.
Okay.
And just went off the deep end.
Just started eating,
Huh?
Yeah.
That was a story.
Be In beautiful.
Didn't work for them.
I mean,
you know,
his wife cheated on him.
Well,
I don't know if it was ever beautiful.
I don't know.
How beautiful did.
What was potential for beauty is.
Yeah.
Good guy though,
man.
He was a really good guy.
He's a fun guy.
Always around store.
He still.
What did he do back there?
He worked for the door to door for
awhile.
He had that east coast flavor.
I'll tell you what,
the dude.
He was fucking funny on stage too.
Yeah.
I saw fat james have some funny sets.
He was ridiculous.
Did a couple stints
on a always sunny in Philadelphia.
Diddy.
Absolutely,
dude.
He had some.
He of get some acting work after awhile.
You hear?
Is this him trying to get on this?
They're trying to put him up on a
mechanical bull.
Oh my God.
Great Hair.
He's so big.
One flip and he's down.
Remember him taking a shower?
He plopped.
This is.
Oh God.
Oh,
that's so hilarious.
this is so funny.
Jimmy and Joey.
Wow.
Check it out.
I'm getting nostalgic,
man.
You know,
I've actually been Jimmy and the Jimmy
and joey were phenomenal.
Just once,
just on a whim.
The Jimmy and Joey.
What for those that don't know Jimmy and
joey is like a.
it's like a double andrew dice clay.
Do you know like brothers version of
edge,
like Jimmy and Joey,
don't you?
From the back and forth.
It's like,
oh,
come on.
Italians don't like Jehovah's Witnesses.
I don't know what job is.
Windows.
Oh,
tell us don't like any witnesses and
they just go back and forth with the
setup and then the punchline.
I remember those guys.
So there was always different Jimmy's
fat Jameson.
And at one point I was a Jimmy James was
the Jimmy.
Oh,
I get what you're saying.
So you played during the show.
So
I just did it once.
Oh,
that's funny.
So they use like,
they have fake names.
Well yeah,
there's the will.
The original Jimmy was really named
Jimmy.
That's fascinating subject because I
know that guys have sold their acts to
other people.
Like do you remember that guy who had
defending the caveman?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Broadway thing.
Yeah.
What was that guy's name?
I don't know his name because he was a
standup and really a fascinating story
because uh,
he made a ton of money.
Yes he did.
He did.
Um,
he was a standup and he put together
like he put a stand up together in the
form of like a one man show and it
became very popular.
Uh,
Rob Becker is his name,
but then he started like selling it to
people that they could do it,
like actors,
so they could all do it all at once.
All over the country.
Yeah.
Michael Chiklis did it.
No kidding.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No kidding.
I'm almost positive.
Hold on.
Let me pull this up real soon because
they're definitely doing that show in
Vegas every time I'm there.
By the way.
Michael Chiklis,
if you read it,
I'm a huge fan.
He's the shield,
right?
Yeah.
I love that.
The commish yeah.
I'm not goofing on.
Your men did one episode of Seinfeld.
Are we talking about the same guy?
Yeah,
Michael Chiklis.
He was also a the thing in the fantastic
four.
Oh yeah,
he did.
Yeah,
he did his Broadway debut in the one man
show defending the caveman.
So I was correct.
We don't even need the internet.
I just sort of remember it because I was
like,
wow,
that's weird.
But I guess I guess it makes sense,
but to a comic,
it's weird.
Like,
you know,
like you were going to buy an act like
all of a sudden,
like he like few.
For instance,
let's say when you.
What year did you start out?
A 98.
90 eight.
What if instead of you doing your act,
what if Dave attell just sold you his
act?
Oh,
I would love it.
And you would go on stage and you would
do like say like a classic albums.
Thanks for the memories,
which is my favorite hotel.
If you went onstage and his and just did
it as Dave attell and it would be.
That would be called the skanks for the
memory show.
Right?
And you would hire an actor to do it.
That's weird.
It's really weird.
And God damn it.
I wish that was available.
You want you to think though that like
there are two totally different things
is why it's weird.
And when you,
when you turn stand up into a one man
show,
then you can get away with anything
because it's a clearly defined one man
show and it's just defending the caveman
one man show.
Absolutely.
As a comic you never do that?
No.
No,
no,
you can't do it because every year you
have to have a new act.
Right?
So this what,
what's going on?
Is it that this guy figured out a way to
take stand up but transport it into a
safe zone.
Right.
And then just drop it off where it
exists in perpetuity,
right?
No more rules.
And now this can be done at the same
time in all 50 states and you get you in
a way.
You get all the money from it so you
don't have to tour as much.
You stay in Vegas and do it.
Well,
all your minions do it around the
country.
That is fucking weird.
What if you started charging show,
making the full charge show?
Yeah.
You were showing the full charge show.
You would show it in Los Angeles and
select markets.
Then you would give people licenses to
do it in Atlanta.
First of all,
all,
all my minions will have to be called
the half charge.
But what do you do for a living?
I'm a half charge.
So you do the full charges jokes.
Do you write your own jokes?
I have a lot of my own stuff,
but mostly today people want to hear the
full charge,
so that's what I do for now.
It's just,
you know,
it's not my dream.
I'm basically a cover band.
Yeah.
This is what pays the bills and then I
do my own stuff at open mics around
Atlantic city,
but it is fascinating that in our art
form,
the pretentious title that you give to
standup comedy that we all give it.
You're not allowed to do that,
but in almost every other kind of music
you people do that.
Movies or music or any other kind of
entertainment,
right?
Terentino's straight up.
Yeah.
Like copies other movies and it's known
as an Oma.
Right.
But like with standup,
it's very sacred to us because I think
it's just because you don't get paid as
much.
That's probably exactly what it is.
We're just fun.
Where's my piece?
We got our rules.
Oh,
we certainly.
Because it's not.
It's not documented.
When we do our stuff,
not necessarily will you.
If you have to have.
You not only have to have rules for
other people,
you have to have rules for yourself too.
You have to.
Everybody has to keep everybody honest
because the idea of creativity and the
idea of originality and unique thoughts
and the origin of thoughts.
It's pretty important to us because it's
all we have.
All comic has essentially is what he's
created in his own mind and then put to
paper our keyboard and then transfers to
the stage.
That's all you have as a comic.
That's all you have.
You can jazz it up and dance with it and
do all kinds of shit,
but if you don't have the raw material,
you don't have anything.
Exactly.
That's why for us that that honesty
process is super important.
I also think it's one of the cool things
about what we do that we have so many
comic friends that were constantly
interacting with on a regular basis.
It's always joey and Ari and Duncan and
you and score and fucking Christ and all
super cool,
super honest,
super above board people.
Right,
and so you know,
don't even want to do something that's
similar to somebody else.
To have known desire and drop shit in a
heartbeat.
When you find out that it's too close to
something that.
Exactly.
Just go fuck it.
It's over the last you want to hear
someone's comparing you to someone else
now also you get to hang with and joke
around with the funniest dudes on the
planet.
Yeah,
because we all trust each other to just
fuck around.
Like we all trust each other.
Like,
like Ari was.
I forget what the subject was.
We were joking around about something
the other day and I'm like,
dude,
you got to do that onstage.
And we started working on how he would
do it onstage.
Like what are you feel like this or like
that.
And when you do that,
like that camaraderie.
When you do that for each other,
like you both have an idea or one of you
has an idea and the other one tries to
enhance it and help each other.
That boost boost a saw.
Like I'll get off stage to grow,
have a tagline for me after he said
that,
like maybe that you're calling so much
easier to write for someone else
sometimes because like there's no
pressure on what you wrote and you just
get to sit back and watch the other
person do it.
Then something pops into your head and
you can just give it like you don't.
I mean it's just all inspiration.
Have you ever tried to write for someone
specifically though for their staff?
Sat down and tried to write for someone?
No.
I know a lot of guys have done that
though.
Like I know,
um,
uh,
there was a lot of guys that were
helping Chris,
Chris rock when he was putting together
one of his hbo specials and I think the
Pollo might've been one of them.
I believe Rich Vos,
Louis ck definitely wrote for Chris Rock
I think because it will also.
Chris was doing so many different things
at the same time and probably doing
movies and shit and I think he just
liked to have all those minds to help
him go over his stuff,
which is,
that's a ballsy move,
you know,
have all these bad motherfuckers.
Right.
Cool.
Jokes for you.
I know.
And I'll also work with you creating the
jokes so you get like the opinions of
all these expert comedians.
I mean that's a real ballsy move because
a lot of comedians don't want to be
judged on their performances,
but when you're bringing in guys like,
like Louis C,
k to write for you,
I mean you're going to get the real
deal.
You're going to get me.
So we're going to be the most honest
assessment ever of the material and like
a bunch of masterminds like gearing
together and putting together this
perfect masterpiece comedy.
Do you personally think that's good
though?
I think that's.
Yeah,
I think that's weird.
It's good.
No,
it's not what I do,
but it's.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I think Chris Rock has one of the
greatest comedians of all time and if
that's how he did it brilliantly and
it's right there on the credits.
Oh,
100 percent by such and such,
such and such.
I know Eddie Murphy did it on raw
keenan.
Ivory Wayans wrote on raw.
Absolutely nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with it.
What it's,
you know,
especially because of the way they did
it,
which is so above board.
They let everybody know they were doing
it.
No one,
no one hit that.
And not only that,
it's like what's wrong with bringing in
writers?
There's nothing wrong with it.
It's not unethical.
It's not uncreative.
Just because you're creating with other
people,
it doesn't mean you're not still
creating and actually be very inspiring.
Yes.
You know,
and uh,
and it could get rid of a lot of doubt.
Yeah.
As far as like,
they're like,
this is what you're doing.
That's good.
This is,
you can use this,
blah,
blah.
It's exciting to.
Plagiarism is the problem.
It's not going to operation cooperation
and paid cooperation,
which is essentially what writing is.
Writing for content is great.
It sounds like a great idea.
I don't do it that way,
but I would.
I think it's really common.
It's just really personal for me,
so it's like when you're involving
somebody else's idea of what they think
she should sound like.
To me that's just gross.
You got a badge and Chris rock went up
at the seller,
did what he had and then the other guys
contributed.
That's what I'm imagining.
I'm very sure of that and then spice
things up or added or had an idea.
Maybe Chris could run it out.
Just be this.
Getting all of his jokes and his guys.
He was getting a little juice,
little here and there,
little spark and you're getting it from
like hungry guys who are really good.
They're,
you know,
they're out there.
He's like,
he's not like,
Hey Louis,
c k,
let's talk about your divorce in my.
I hear what you're saying too though.
What I agree with you in a lot of ways
is that like it's very personal,
but even though it's very personal,
like sometimes another eye on what
you're doing,
they'll open you up to like,
oh,
I didn't even think of that.
And then like,
why?
Oh,
why was I doing it that way?
Because if I didn't,
if I didn't say that,
it would like open up the whole back end
of it.
Like there's,
there's a lot of times like some things
that your friends can see that you don't
say.
I know a lot of comics that actually
have writers and that to me always felt
really weird because it seems like
they're just actors or the boyfriends
boyfriend to call a writer.
What if felt like I came up with this
black peoples and this Nigga I got this
idea when
it started to get bigger and blacker a
white guy starts doing the bigger and
blacker tour and just does all the.
Well,
there was a guy doing that for Hicks
man,
which I thought was really weird.
Yeah.
There's a guy that was doing like Hicks
as a one man show here are,
you know,
the guy was doing,
uh,
Bill Hicks as a one man show.
God impersonating Bill Hicks is a one
man.
Show me Google this.
That's weird because Bill Hicks still
isn't famous.
Oh,
I think he's pretty famous.
Is Larry still around?
Is he on a show or something?
I know they want to craig gas to do a,
a,
um,
a kinison vegas thing.
Well,
he does an incredible.
Yes in impression.
Um,
I can't find it here anywhere.
There was,
there was a guy,
I'm very positive that there was a guy
who was trying to put together a one man
show and he was just going to do bill
Hicks like,
like Mark Twain,
sort of a thing.
She could go up and do mark Twain today
because Mark Twain has been dead for a
long time.
Fucking people are happy to see you.
No one's going to know what he really
was like and be like,
pitch.
That is not how mark twain talks.
We focused.
This is terrible.
This is fucking terrible.
At the pipe down.
You're holding the pipe or the left.
He helped with the right.
Oh God.
But a guy like Hicks,
like,
you know,
I saw him in the flesh.
He didn't die that long ago.
When did you see him and where did you
see him?
I saw him a couple times.
I saw him.
I saw him at least at least three,
possibly four occasions meeting.
I saw him for an entire weekend.
Okay.
And uh,
it was all when he was visiting Boston,
he was a big,
like touring pro coming off of the
Rodney dangerfield special was like just
starting to catch heat right as I got
into comedy.
So I was lucky enough to be at a point
where the clubs of let me come by like
an open mic or.
But the clubs would let me in on a
Friday night and I could watch God.
There's no way I was working with them
and I was terrible,
but they would let me come in and watch
them at the comedy connection.
The way they ran it and nick's and all
those places in Boston.
It was so cool because they,
they had great comics.
Would come in every weekend.
You'd have guys that would come in like
dom irrera.
I saw him there.
They would.
They would all come like and have like a
big name headliner.
But they also had this insane community,
have really great comedy around there as
well.
And the way they did it is because they
super supported open milkers super
supported the new talent.
They knew that new talent is what
becomes headliners one day and you have
to nurture it.
And they were like big about that.
So when a guy like Hicks was in town,
they would tell me like,
you got to see Hicks.
I'm Paul Barkley told me.
He was like,
you gotta see this guy.
He's fucking tremendous.
I go,
that's the guy from the HBO special.
Right?
And he's just like,
yeah,
but you got to see him.
Like he's just,
he's on another level.
And then I remember seeing him for the
first time and going,
whoa.
Like guys say they don't a fuck.
Give a fuck.
Everybody gives a fuck man.
I always give a fuck if I give a fuck
right now.
Fuck what I'm stumbling through a
squarespace commercial.
I can't get my fat tongue to work.
I give a fuck at the supermarket.
I don't want to look dumb.
Bill Hicks did not give a fuck man.
I'm telling you.
I saw the first guy in my life that
didn't honestly didn't give a fuck on
stage when I saw him because the first
time I saw him we saw him twice in the
same time period.
He came,
he was at the comedy connection and then
he came to nick so shortly thereafter
and I got to see them in both places.
The comedy connection was,
was pretty fucking fascinating.
But when he came to nick's,
he went on after a guy that was doing
like impressions of different,
different cartoon animals,
smoking pot.
He had like literally had copped donut
jokes.
Um,
I mean he was the guy who we went on
before.
It was a funny guy.
He,
but he was,
it wasn't the same style of comedy by
any stretch of the imagination.
It was terrible setup for Bill Hicks
because it was all like really dopey,
you know,
base shitty comedy.
Right.
Alright.
Hooks goes on after him and just eats
fat piles of Shit,
just giant plates and plates of Shit and
it's by the end of the show,
there's maybe 300 people in this
displacement,
let's say to 50.
There's maybe 50 left at the end of the
show.
Walk the entire crowd except for 50
people and me,
Greg Fitzsimmons and like three or four
other local Boston comics.
I can't remember the name.
We were fucking crying.
He didn't give a fuck.
He was doing his bits as if he was
killing and they were all dying.
Right?
Everything was dying.
The crowd just did not bite except for
this small core people that were in the
back that were howling and the comics
now.
I just worked with somebody recently in
Indianapolis who has been around for a
long time and he said,
Bill Hicks had a lot more dick jokes.
Then you think,
oh yeah,
well he used to joke around about it.
Spice up,
you know,
any other topic.
You just throw Dick Jokes in between
them to keep people interested.
He would joke around about having to do
that right where he joked,
but folks,
Dick Jokes are coming.
I've heard that big fat via.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
I mean he was a fascinating comic to me
because he represents me.
I've had arguments with Ari about him
because he doesn't think he was funny.
He's a funny guy,
but he's honest about it.
He tells me,
he goes,
it's not funny.
He's like,
he's giving makes really good points,
but he's not funny.
What?
What I.
I disagree.
I always laugh at him.
I laughed at him when I saw him in
[inaudible] 88.
I laugh at it now,
but what I think he represents is the
first guy that started looking at what
you talk about on stage completely
differently.
Like he started to a young man on acid.
Like that whole bit about what?
About a positive.
It was really powerful.
Like the non.
What was non bullshit talk?
It was.
Was it a way?
It was like when he was doing like
certain bits,
he wasn't just doing a bit.
He was doing a bit that plants a seed
and gets you thinking about a subject
differently because he's mocked it so
well that it whenever you try to
seriously bring up the war on drugs
after you've heard Bill Hicks talk about
it,
you seem like an asshole.
Right,
right,
right.
Did he just had a.
It was a fascinating way of mixing ideas
into comedy in it.
I think the most powerful way since
Lenny Bruce,
I personally think he's the most
powerful at it because his,
his impact is felt by I think a
different era because of the,
uh,
because of Youtube.
But because of the videos and the audio
that's available,
the,
the Lenny Bruce Stuff,
if you've tried to go back and listen to
it now,
it doesn't really hold up anymore.
It's weird.
So you can tell why it was
groundbreaking at the time,
but now it's just like,
Huh.
It's very like beat poet.
Very like,
yeah,
rambling Hicks.
I was on a totally different lens did in
the eighties too,
you know,
like where there wasn't really a need
for that.
Yeah,
it was the Reagan administration and the
Bush one administration and people were
getting by on who's squeezes the bottom
of the toothpaste.
You know,
and I'm no disrespect to Seinfeld,
I can't believe.
Where is that song?
What's the deal?
I can't believe whenever I think about
Bill Hicks,
I just can't believe he was dead and
gone at 32.
Yeah,
that blows my mind.
And when you're talking about that acid
joke that's on tape one dangerous when
he was 27.
It's a brilliant.
Yeah,
I mean St I don't want to show you a
tape of me and when I was 26,
you don't want to see tape of him when
he was 17 because he was funny.
He was 17.
He was going up at the fucking Houston
annex and move 17 and was good.
I know and he was clean and he,
I mean clean as far as like his delivery
was clean.
It was really good stuff.
It wasn't the embarrassing shit that
would represent you or I know he would
get lost in just.
This is based on the documentary that
just came out.
I saw a couple of years ago he would get
lost and characters of his family and
like he was just crazy funny and they
keep it just as good as the guys that
were twice as age fucking pancreatic
cancer.
Crazy,
crazy fucking disease.
That's a bad one to allegedly.
Well,
a lot of it is cigarettes.
A lot of people believe that there's a
correlation between cigarettes.
Pancreas is a thing you can remove,
right?
It's like,
does nothing.
No extra parts.
Right?
Take it out and I'll be a lighter.
Brian's education is based on operation.
The board game,
appendix,
right?
Uh,
you can take your tonsils,
your appendix,
I think.
Yes,
you can take in your wisdom 10 decks.
You definitely take out your appendix.
What causes pancreatic cancer?
Uh,
aside from advanced age,
smoking is the main risk factor.
Oh,
great.
A smoker's three to four times more
likely than a nonsmoker to a acquire
pancreatic cancer is your pancreas at
who knows inside that that body thing.
Cage,
like in the main part,
the main part,
like a bulletproof vest.
Cover it under the flip cage.
What the fuck?
Man?
Cigarettes or so senior arm and Hicks
smoked a lot of cigarettes and did jokes
about smoking,
argued for cigarettes,
pancreatic cancer.
Got Them motherfuckers.
Well,
so many really talented artists have
smoke cigarettes.
It's weird.
It's sad.
It's sad a lot of ways because it's like
when I see a cigarette smoker,
I don't see a person exercising their
freedom.
I know that's what they're doing.
If they want to smoke,
they should be able to smoke for sure,
but that's not what I see.
I see a person who's enslaved.
Yes.
That's what I see.
I see enslavement to a habit and also to
a drug at the same time.
It's just another addiction.
It's just another thing to do but it
kills you to kills a lot of.
Doesn't get you high,
but it's also a weird thing that you
would get addicted to taking something
lighting on fire and then putting it up
to your mouth and then breathing it in
like that.
Just the ritual of doing that can become
so ingrained in your life that it
represents something like after sex,
like people.
Some people like to smoke a cigarette
after sex.
That's like a classic movie scene,
right,
where people have sex and then they
smoke a cigarette you,
but if you really like,
what are you watching?
They're watching someone poisoning
themselves,
like that's a weird thing to find
romantic.
That's a weird thing they snuck in on us
and how it becomes habit study finds no
link between secondhand smoke and cancer
funded by the tobacco lobbyists of
America in Florida.
It's in Florida.
If you have a case that goes through in
Florida,
it might as well go through on the moon.
They're not.
Americans are tired of people saying the
Florida's America to stop.
We need to cut it out.
Even flip live.
My parents live in Florida.
Don't get me wrong,
I love Florida,
but that shit is not America.
That is some crazy spot where you can't.
Any studies that come out of there,
who knows?
Who knows what kind of coke they were on
when they made that study?
They can't even trust him to vote.
Right.
I mean,
that's fucked up.
That's interesting.
Nicotine and tobacco linked to heart
disease.
Well,
nicotine speeds up your heart rate,
doesn't it?
It makes it work harder than it has to.
Well,
I've heard of nicotine being given as a
supplement before,
which is really bizarre.
Or as medicine before,
I think it was for a heart issue.
I find just like anything else in small
doses,
every once in a while I that bad,
but a pack a day delivered through
fucking cancer,
a smoke and it's so hot.
Yeah.
Well a lot of stuff is like that,
man.
We were talking yesterday with Shane
Smith from vice about that devil
Columbian Devil's breath.
It's called [inaudible] or something
like that.
It's dangerous.
The most dangerous drug.
It's the same shit that's in those
little seasickness tabs that they put on
you.
You know,
those things that you get stick they
stick on you and the seasickness is
supposed to be mitigated by this.
That's the same shit at the Columbian
Devil's breath stuff,
but it's just like way more way more
patches,
like barely giving you a hit.
They're giving you just a taste.
How do you take this dangerous stuff?
Do you smoke it?
You swallow it,
you shoot it.
What do you do?
Uh,
I think they can blow it in your face
and you just have it in your face and
you breathe,
just breathing it in,
like having it blown in your mouth and
your nose.
You got it,
you're done.
And then you become like,
literally,
like a little Zombie.
They tell you what to do.
I can tell you,
go to your bank account,
take out money for me.
And people do.
And like they have video of people doing
this.
Wow.
Indeed.
And it's the same fucking thing that you
can get from these patches,
these dermal patches for sisense.
And then people go,
don't be seasick.
I concentrate on the horizon.
Don't take anything else,
give me $500.
It's,
don't take those fucking don't think
drama mean I took drama,
mean,
oh my God,
I went into a dark dark coma.
What is drawing me mean?
I don't know.
Drama man,
pussies pussies like me that,
uh,
get on a boat and start getting sick.
Right?
Right,
right.
Well,
apparently it alleviates nausea.
Uh,
but for me it was like a tranquilizer
dart.
It alleviated everything else to include
in your sight.
And your hearing even was seriously,
my body was like this,
we were,
it was me and my buddy Jimmy,
and luckily he didn't take the drama
mean and uh,
we were at the uh,
the diner on the way home and I was just
sitting in front of him nodding out like
a heroin addict and he's like,
you all right over there.
He,
you know,
he might have actually taken a drama,
mean to.
He was a lot bigger than me.
Jimmy was like 200 plus pounds and that
was probably at the time I was
competing.
So it was probably about 155 pounds and
I took this one drama main or to drama
names.
I don't know how many they gave me,
but I was gone.
So I wake up,
I woke up the next day.
Really?
Did you enjoy it on you?
And Joe was terrible.
I took too much probably.
I probably tried to take as much as he
was taken.
I don't know what I'm going to ask you
all.
If you take two,
I'll take two.
Two guys doing guys.
Especially that.
I mean,
we were both teenagers,
right?
That uh,
but it fucking knocked my dick right in
the dirt.
Is that a prescription drug?
I think so.
It might be an over the counter.
I don't know.
I mean the laws might've changed since,
uh,
this is a long ass time ago.
Who knows?
Her formula might have changed too.
Right?
But apparently I'm too much of a pussy
to even take a drama,
drama,
drama me knowledge time.
It doesn't do anything to them,
not me.
I'm literally,
we're eating and I'm sitting here like
this why we're eating sit straight.
It felt so pathetic.
It's pathetic when you falling asleep
and someone asks you,
are you falling asleep?
Like,
no.
Right.
Like why am I afraid to admit that I'm
falling asleep?
Oh yeah.
When people call me,
I always like,
hey man,
what's up?
Are you sleeping?
I'm sorry?
Did like you always lie about something
feminine about sleeping,
man,
I'm a man.
I don't sleep.
That's exactly what it is for weak bitch
men
like ourselves for weak bitch cells.
We don't want to admit facing my engine
right now.
I'm up at 6:00
every morning and doing sit ups
crunches.
I've worked my obliques.
I don't sleep much sleep.
It's like,
Oh God,
if the guy's really trying to be
intimidating,
he says he doesn't need much sleep.
I gotta go vote,
you know,
four hours sleep at night and I got it.
I got shit to do.
I'm good.
I'm good for hours.
I'll to the house at 2:00
in the afternoon.
Motherfuckers asleep on the couch.
Was Dick in his hand watching days of
our life with an open laptop nearby.
Truly the fuck up bitch.
I had shit to do.
You need to sleep.
Everybody needs sleep.
How dare you.
Sleep is the best I think you can get by
on like if you really want to have like
a low level mindset,
you can get by on four hours sleep for a
couple days in a row,
but after that,
let's be honest.
Like you're not functioning very well.
You're,
you're imbalanced.
Four hours.
Sleep at night.
Yeah.
You stood to have weird thoughts.
Your brain doesn't work properly.
It needs his rest.
Maybe you bro.
None me for hours.
I'm good.
You don't mind.
Rem cycles are just very deep that go
deep right away.
I'm confident in myself,
so I go to sleep very quickly.
I'm not worried about predators.
I go out and get it.
I get all my work done,
my sleep work.
I get it done in four hours.
My body is a unusual.
It's very wolverine.
Like if I get it scratched,
people can't believe.
The next day I'll quick.
It's healed.
It's just me,
bro.
It's just not normal.
Not Normal.
This is the Jimmy and joey sketch.
This is a repeat every four hours a day.
Sleep guy.
That's my new character.
Two thousand 13.
I slept 16 hours so I don't give a fuck.
You know,
I got a lot done.
I have a new web series and working on
right now.
I'm very happy with built a shelf.
You know,
we had a fire to producer this fucking
asshole.
See my vision,
but this guy sleeps six hours a day.
Lazy piece of Shit.
Where were we?
Wrap up at midnight.
I will see you guys at five.
He was like,
no,
we need to turn around fucking
turnaround.
I'm here to work for production.
People are like,
I've heard you rag on that before.
They're savages.
They,
they,
they push people to work at ungodly
hours and it's like standard in
Hollywood.
Fourteen hours is like regular total.
Especially if you're working on a single
camera drama show like those Csi shows
and the other like those.
I don't know,
I'm wanting to say that one in
particular,
but a lot of those single camera like
cop shows,
those fucking people are working 16
hours a day,
six days a week and the [inaudible]
season is forever.
It takes forever to get 27 episodes of
Aqap show done just so they can be like,
I work in the movies.
It's crazy.
It's for folks that work on,
on sets,
it's like,
um,
there was a show that I did this hunting
show that I do and when you want to talk
about people that work hard to just show
meat eater.
And this dude who hosted,
his name is Steven Rinella and he's got
these guys that work for them
specifically.
This guy,
Dan Toady and moe's the director and
these fucking guys are working 16 hours
a day on top of a mountain somewhere,
freezing their asses off in a fucking
tent and this is what they do every
week.
Every week they're flying a fucking
Mexico to hunt a buffalo or flying to
the Swiss Alps to kill some crazy sheep
or something like that.
Right?
They got to kill animals and Itam on top
of all these hours.
Well,
they don't have to do that.
They don't sometimes.
Like sometimes they don't get an animal
at all really,
but the thing is like these guys that
are working behind the scenes,
like the cameraman,
stuff like that.
The guys were carrying shit like what a
fucking hard,
you know,
to be expected to work like that.
Like wow,
you've got to find some special fucking
people that are willing to work like
that.
Camping,
we're going to go,
I don't get to stop work at this.
No.
Stop work.
When you're working,
you fucking work while you're there.
When you're not working,
you're sleeping.
You get up and everybody works again.
No insomnia and production life.
No,
you're not allowed to,
and they knock out the 40 hour work week
in about two and a half day in the
adderall flows like hail falls from the
sky.
Just pick it up and stuffed it into
their mouth.
A lot of that.
No,
I don't know.
Just guessing.
I would say that if you were working on
a set of like a show that was working
like crazy hours all the time,
you probably need at least a strong
energy drink.
Habit,
coffee.
Don't cut it at that point.
Coffee.
Don't cut it.
Especially if you're not working on
something for you.
All right?
If you're working on the mat,
fold tron experience,
Kaboom,
and you've got an energy.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you have a chart and you're.
You're plotting your future.
Take over.
You know what I'm saying?
I know half George.
You just,
you're figuring out how you're going to
set up these one man shows around the
country who keep your comedy in a time
capsule and they have all these people
become the half charges.
You're going to be fine,
right?
But if you're working on like that 70
[inaudible] show or something like that,
how sad example,
but you know something,
some ridiculous show,
some show where you don't give a fuck
about the outcome,
not just a job and you're there all day
and you're there all day and you get to
see whiny actors throw hissy fits and
throw fucking scripts around to see the
weirdness between the crew and the
actors and Oh,
fucking shit.
The amount of time invested put in all
that.
I know it's crazy because a regular
person has a regular job.
Like you work nine,
you've done five.
Maybe you have some extra things you
have to tie up before you leave the
office.
Right?
The office by six and like that's very.
That's a lot of time.
And let's be honest,
there's some youtube and in there
there's some office gods has been there.
That's all your fucking employee really
deserves.
Your employer rather employer doesn't
deserve your 100 percent of your time
here because it's your life.
That shit's ridiculous to have a job
that sucks.
You drive for 16 hours a day.
It's almost,
it's almost like you,
it's obviously,
I believe that people should have the
free to do whatever the fuck they want.
They want to pursue that sort of alive.
But if you,
if it's not something you enjoy doing,
that's a really dangerous place to put
your brain,
right?
The fact that,
okay,
this is what we do.
We do stuff that sucks for 16 hours a
day where you hate it and then you get
to be free.
Some people don't want a life or don't
want their own thoughts though.
Is that what it is?
Some people like to keep themselves busy
and there's a little bit of that in
standup comedy.
It's like,
I don't want to do Valentine's Day.
I got to work that night,
honey.
Well,
I see,
I understand what it is as far as like
the production budgets and um,
you know,
getting things done.
And if days take longer,
takes more time,
cost more money.
And so in order to fit things under
budget or in their budget,
they have to work these long hours,
you know,
that's just what they do and that
there's,
if they don't get a 12 hour turnaround,
like they have to pay penalties and they
pay meal penalties and all these union
penalties that they have to pay if they.
But at the end of the day it's like,
why is everybody choosing to work so
crazy?
Like I don't know.
At the end of the day I understand you
save a little money this way.
I get it.
Is there another way?
There is another way it's called.
It's shorter hours.
Woody Allen does it.
Does he?
Television does it a lot of times.
Fuck yeah,
they sit.
Does sitcoms do it?
Yeah.
By the time news radio is in its fifth
season,
we only worked three days a week.
Nice.
Yeah.
Some we had done two days a week.
We had done one day when we got the
script and as we were going over the
script,
we have block and and like mark where
the scenes are going to take place and
that's what we'd rehearse it,
go over it,
do one run through and then film with
the next day.
Did you,
do you really enjoy doing that show?
I really enjoyed doing that show,
but I don't think I would really enjoy
doing another show.
Gotcha.
Unless it was like that.
Right.
You know,
like that was a really weird show
because that show was.
I don't know how it is on most sitcoms
because I've only.
The only other one I've done is just
shoot me.
I did one episode of that.
I did one episode of Mad TV.
I did.
I didn't really do much other than that,
but when I was on news radio and they
let us ad Lib like almost every scene.
That's awesome.
Like almost every scene there was
something that was changed,
something that was altered,
something that was someone,
one of us came up with on the fly and
most of the time orchestrated by Dave
Foley.
Like Day Foley would take the script and
then he was,
he was sort of,
it was an ensemble show,
but if anybody was the lead,
it was day four and it was Phil Hartman
who was the big star and then,
you know,
Dave Foley was,
kind of like,
I always felt like he was like a,
like an uncredited producer really.
Right.
And he would orchestrate like a lot of
the scenes and come up with fantastic
lines for them to.
He's a really fucking talented guy.
And then all the guys that I think don't
get appreciated enough for being fucking
unbelievably hilarious.
One of them is Dave Foley.
He's such a sweetheart of a guy,
like always has been.
Always been like the nicest,
kindest guy and really,
really,
really fucking smart.
Really fucking smart and really fucking
funny to such a cool dude.
Always was now.
And I'm and,
and I think he's doing standup now to
really.
Yeah.
That's not his background,
right?
He's more of an Improv guys.
He was a,
he was one of the guys from kids in the
hall.
Yeah,
I know that much.
Yeah.
You've watched kids in the hall?
Yeah,
but after the fact I watched it like
after it was,
you know,
reruns.
So good.
Yeah.
It's such a fucking good stuff.
So good.
What was that on originally?
Canadian television.
What was that on?
What?
Like kids in the hall?
Where did it originally aired?
That's a good question.
I think it was Canadian.
Yeah,
I think it was Canadian TV.
Yeah.
And then we found out about it in
America and then those kinds of came
down here.
But,
um,
I don't remember my original point.
I just got product caught up in this
Dahlia production.
It's insane.
When you were asking me that was where
it was,
you were asking me whether or not,
uh,
I enjoyed doing it.
I said I enjoyed doing it,
but the way it was done was so wild and
crazy.
Almost after every filming everybody was
getting hammered more drunken moment
talks with like Maura Tierney and day
fall within any other humans in my whole
life.
That's these like crate and especially
for me back then like,
oh,
it's such an emotional mess.
Really.
Yeah.
Because I was,
you know,
my late twenties,
I had just gotten into,
stand up,
just got done fighting,
just gotten into stand up and then moved
out to la and I didn't know what the
fuck I was doing.
I didn't believe I was on TV two years
ago.
I was broke as fuck,
right.
Barely getting by as a comic and then
all of a sudden I'm sitting here with
Dave fucking Foley and Phil Hartman and
we're going over the lines of the show
we're on.
I'm like,
I didn't make any sense.
So you had trouble accepting that or it
was just like weird.
It's just weird.
So crazy.
And so,
you know,
we had these wild drunken fucking
parties after the,
after the shows for time,
like they were crazy.
They were very punk rock.
Dave Foley like really embraced some
sort of a punk ideology for the whole
thing.
And the producers,
like,
especially Paul Simms who was the guy
who created it,
wrote it,
the head writer,
and he would just let the funniest stuff
go through.
Like he just wanted it to be the
funniest.
So he wrote,
he wrote really funny shit and really
creative shit and they would let you
know,
Phil Hartman ad Lib or Andy Dick and
Andy Dick ad libbed a lot of shit.
Yeah.
He would just take something and just
run with it,
you know,
figure out a better way to do it.
And everybody was always tweaking their
lines.
They're always trying to figure out
like,
what is this?
Is it this or is it just a.
Oh yeah,
that one,
you know,
we would help each other like that.
I think that's,
I don't really know,
but I kinda think that's a huge vote.
Paul.
And a lot of sitcoms.
You respect the writers.
Is this flubs?
Yeah,
Ben's a bloopers.
I made to take a piss.
It's unbelievable.
I can't believe that.
I don't know this.
Uh,
so great.
It was awesome.
I think it will be called free.
Willie's billy free.
Billy's Willie Bell.
That's so crazy.
I remember that flub count for freaks.
Yeah,
it's funny.
Fun Times,
man.
Yeah.
But what he was talking about was,
or what are the.
The question was whether I would do
something like that again,
like you'd never find a show like that.
They're probably never going to make one
like that again.
That show went under the radar.
It was like while it was on,
it was a,
it was so like ignored that it was sort
of allowed to be what it became because
they fucked with it a little bit.
Like I know they brought in like a
couple of romantic characters and they
brought a woman into the office once.
You're not Lauren Graham,
the woman from the Gilmore girls
Saturday.
Lauren Graham?
I think so.
We'll find.
Is that her name?
She's so hot.
She's really cool.
She was on news radio for a season.
Yeah.
So was um,
Patrick Warburton.
The guy when you go to a soaring over
California,
is that it?
Lauren Green Long Graham.
She's really fucking funny and really
cool.
Like,
you know,
a lot of actresses.
They're like,
when you're talking to them,
you're talking to your representative.
Do you ever try?
No.
That we worked together.
She's a very cool though.
Very nice person.
She was fun to hang with.
Like,
she's like,
she,
she could joke around,
she was lively,
they brought her in,
but other than that they didn't really,
um,
didn't really fuck with it,
you know,
they kind of let Paul to his thing and
that's why it was so weird.
I just,
unless he get a show like that.
No,
because once you do a show like that,
you realize like,
that's like I went from a show before
that we did a show on Fox called
hardball and hardball.
Was this like really bad show baseball?
It was terrible.
Fucking terrible.
And there was a mascot that was a big
baseball.
Yeah.
And the show was awesome and got
destroyed.
Okay.
Guys who wrote it?
Jeff Martin and Kevin currently believe
they,
um,
they were for writers from married with
children.
There were writings from the sentence,
really funny guys.
They were really good and they put
together this fucking bad ass script and
the pilot was like really well written.
It was really good stuff.
And then as soon as the show got picked
up,
these guys were kind of like,
they were a soft spoken to really
friendly,
really nice guys.
And just kind of soft spoken and the
network didn't think that they were
strong enough to run a show like they
thought you needed to be strong.
So they booted these guys out and it
brought in this super duper hacker,
richest dude.
I mean,
he was a hacker [inaudible].
It was terrible.
Like every terrible cliche in a scene.
This guy would insert in there.
His writing was just insanely bad.
He was from that show,
coach member I've ever coached.
Well he had come from the air somehow or
another and he had gotten on this show
and I watched the show get destroyed.
And so going from that to seeing the
news radio way,
which is a weird thing where no one ever
got famous from the show.
The show was always almost going to get
canceled and limped into five years and
didn't even get to 100 episodes.
We were two episodes shy,
which is like almost for the show,
like prophetic,
you know,
that's,
that's what we are,
which is bad.
But because of that,
because the no pressure,
no start,
um,
no craziness.
No,
not too much.
Network interference.
Brilliant.
Producer.
It became this weird environment where
there's all this ad libbing and all
this,
you know,
rechanging of things in very dynamic and
really funny stuff that you're proud to
tell someone that you worked on.
Right.
So once you've done that,
it's really hard to do a shitty one like
the hardball when again.
Right.
And most likely that's where you're
going to run into this.
It's hard to do.
It's fucking silent movies,
man.
That's what it is.
You gotta you gotta fake laughs and
there's a silent movies.
It's hard to keep that art form alive,
you know.
And so you guys were riffing in front of
the audience while the cameras are
rolling.
Oh yeah.
All the time.
It's so awesome.
We'd written in front of the cameras.
Dave would oftentimes change a line,
like on the fly,
like come up with something that was
funnier because his background had been
live performing.
Right?
So he knew how to come up with stuff on
the fly.
Is that hardball?
Oh God.
I remember when this is on,
it was only on for like six episodes.
I think we did seven,
but only six of them ever made it to the
air.
It's just they just.
It just got butchered,
but that's what happens a lot of the
time because in the business of TV,
what people were trying to do is make a
shitload of money and these producer
guys,
they're there,
they want to control everything and they
want to make a shitload of money and if
they are allowed to,
if they get into a situation where they
do it,
you can't be surprised that they do and
they don't know that their ideas suck.
They think they're awesome,
which is why they have the job.
So they push forward thinking that these
awesome ideas that aren't so awesome
actually are going to change this show
for the better.
Like they're not trying to fuck it up,
but he fucked it up.
When you see stuff like that,
you're like,
I don't.
There's too many people.
I'll just do podcasts.
Yeah,
exactly how many people you've got to
deal with.
So yeah.
Whoops.
I heard Seinfeld talking about how like
that was one of the only shows where
they were like,
no we don't.
I think it was Larry.
David was like,
no outside influences and he was always
willing to walk before he was even
anybody before he even had any money in
the bank.
Well,
I don't know how true that is,
but I bet it's true.
Then they initially like shows always
get fucked with in the beginning.
I mean unless you bring in like unless
it's Martin Scorsese and speed Steven
Spielberg team up together for some new
miniseries.
I'm pretty sure that network is going to
shut the fuck up on that.
Right.
But until that happens,
they have some say and they,
they want to,
they want to throw their own special
spice into the zoo.
I like coriander.
Can we put coriander in this suit?
Yes.
You fuck with your coriander?
I'd throw it in there.
We're watching your soup get ruined.
Right?
There's,
you know,
it's a business.
A lot of people involved.
It's just like anything else.
It's just like the design of a car or
the box that the corn flakes come in.
A lot of people have their say,
a lot of people have opinions and
there's,
you know,
there's a lot of weird desk going on and
you wouldn't,
you know,
as well as I do that when you're trying
to create something,
especially if you try and create
something funny,
the less shit you have coming in,
the better when it comes to like,
like outside of the creative sphere,
you know,
the less people.
Once you get down to a core group of
very competent individuals like writers
and artists are sitting together and
trying to compile the correct way to do
something and they're working on it very
hard if they're a functional group,
that should be where that ends.
Right.
Okay.
When producers come in and they,
all of a sudden they have line reads and
they're like,
well,
why doesn't he just like,
Oh,
fucking Christ.
Why did you hire writers?
Dude,
why don't you just do everything right
when she's here.
Once you write a script that happens all
the time to.
They'll tell a producer once you write a
script,
and a lot of producers think that Ken
writes scripts,
right?
So they'll go and they'll write scripts
and then those writers,
we'll pass it around amongst their
friends and fucking giggle.
Bad.
It sucks.
Right?
I had that on a really small level when
I first started doing stand up,
I got this management group and they're
like,
we're gonna try to base a sitcom around
the fucking five minutes that you
actually have and every month.
And it wasn't just me,
it was a bunch of guys that they managed
every month they would have these shows
where they would go to and then they
would give us suggestions on how to
write sets that would inspire sitcoms.
Wow.
And I actually got pretty far down the
pike with it.
I had like castle rock and we were
pitching and everything.
There was this,
this was 2002,
2002.
Yeah.
Wow.
There was still doing a lot of sitcoms
back then.
There's still the development deal game
back then because that was the first
year of fear factor.
So that was when reality shows were just
starting to take off.
A survivor was first and then was a
couple of other ones and then there was
a,
you know,
NBC had fear factor and a couple of
other ones and then it was just reality
shows like Jon and Kate plus eight and
all these other motherfuckers just
spewed onto the scene.
And then there was the influx of reality
shows over the last decade.
It's pretty crazy.
It's unbelievable.
Two thousand two that wasn't really
going on as much as a lot of sitcoms.
Yeah.
Where's that sweet,
sweet sitcom in the aftermath.
Full trump didn't happen.
I smell a smell.
That sweet,
sweet sitcom money.
Everybody wants that.
Sweet.
I know,
I know.
It's not even a game anymore in a way.
It's not really game.
People go,
wow,
here we go.
Where's
I'm 25 years old and then picture and I
like your little.
You got a little beads on,
you have one of these things on.
It was a,
it was a,
um,
a stainless or a sterling silver
bracelet.
Where'd you find that picture?
A hardball website.
Isn't Jim?
Is Jim backup and see if Jim Burrows in
there and Jim Brewer was in the pilot.
He played the baseball,
the pilot.
They really played the,
uh,
he played the original mascot that got
beat up by the baseball.
He played,
uh,
the Pied Piper because I think we used
to be the pied pipers.
Then we became the pirates or something
like that.
Right.
Or we can whatever the fuck we became,
I forget what the name of the actual
team was,
but a brewer.
The funniest part of the pilot was
brewer brewer dancing around and getting
in a fight with this fucking baseball.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
That's an evil looking baseball right
there
is this guy right here.
Think garland right there.
I'm like,
no,
it's Mike Star.
Mike Star was in the bodyguard.
He was in Goodfellas.
Right.
It's been a lot of movies.
I guarantee you macro recognize if you
saw him.
Super Cool Guy,
man.
That's The star track dad right there.
Captain Kirk's dad to the far left.
Bruce Greenwood.
He was on the show too.
And that's that.
Do this on that.
A kid's show,
you know,
that kid show kitchen,
one of those really popular kid shows.
He plays like he's got a character on.
I,
I catch them on like nickelodeon and all
the time.
And there's Derek jeter that due to the
far right.
Forgot his fucking name man.
He was a cool guy too though.
God dammit.
I can't remember his name.
But uh,
that was the dude that got hit in the
teeth with a pipe in,
in Russia.
I will tell you that story.
Yeah.
A buddy of mine,
that guy was there,
uh,
doing some movie and he turned the
corner and some guys smashed him in the
face of pipe,
knocked him out cold.
His teeth were shattered.
Oh yeah.
He told me matter of faculty to.
He's a tough fucking dude.
So how was Russia?
He goes,
well,
you see these teeth?
Yeah,
I got them because I was in Russia.
I go,
what happened?
This man turned a corner at some dude
smash me in the fucking jaw with a pipe,
broke my teeth out.
That was it.
No complaining and whining.
And I was like,
you know,
I mean,
slick.
No,
everywhere I go,
I worried someone's gonna hit me.
He barely gave a fuck that this guy hit
him in the face of the pipe and not to
have his teeth.
His teeth look better.
Now I'm telling you,
this dude barely gave a fuck.
It was a,
it was a tough dude.
I don't know what he ever went on to do,
but I do know is a really strange thing.
I saw he got something,
some sort of a uh,
like a new show or something like that.
Some,
he got like a,
a part in something that he was really
excited about.
And his girlfriend at the time who was
also an actress,
started openly crying when he received
the good news and
she kept saying like,
when is something going to happen for
me?
Oh,
when is something going to happen for
me?
And she's crying men.
And I was like,
wow,
this port I've,
I felt bad for her brain works that way.
I was like,
this poor kid,
like,
look at this crazy brain pattern.
She's on weird self-absorbed brain
pattern,
but that's the Hollywood way,
man.
That's definitely the acting way.
I mean,
Christ,
a lot of it,
it's a lot of lottery plan.
I mean a lot of them aren't that with
the problem is the,
even the best.
Not that much better than some guy
that's doing community theater in
Oakland,
you know,
it's probably some bad motherfucker that
can't keep his shit together.
Smokes a little bit too much.
Drinks a little bit too much.
But when he gets his shit together and
gets,
you know,
gets a hold of a script,
he could probably fuck it up.
Right.
But he's just never been gotten the
right acting fucking agent or agency or
parts or they always a part of it goes
to and Pharaoh when he gets close,
fuck it.
But the difference between a guy who's
really good and the difference between a
guy who's really famous as far as like
what's valuable in a lot of ways,
it's like how much better is the good
guy?
Then the famous guy,
because you've got to be a lot better
because if you're not a lot better,
I'm going to go with a famous guy
because people go to see if God Damn Tom
Cruise movie,
you know,
so like they,
they have a hard road.
Absolutely.
Show.
Did you see his picture?
So it's like all the guys sitting here
and then you're like,
had a fucking baseball bat that a woman
is Rosemarie.
She's from,
I think it was the Dick van dyke show or
something like that.
Wow.
I think it was the Dick Van Dyke show,
but I remember I was embarrassed that I
didn't know.
Um,
yeah,
I think I never seen the Dick van dyke
show.
It's weird.
I've never seen the Mary Tyler Moore
show.
Well that's not as weird.
The Dick Van Dyke show is weird because
Mary Tyler Moore is really young.
They're A.
Yeah,
she was on the Dick Van Dyke show.
I never watched it.
So when everybody's like,
that's Rosemarie,
like people on the set with like
Rosemary.
And I'm like,
oh,
like what the fuck does that mean?
This is before wikipedia folks.
No one knew anything back then.
God Damn.
We were stupid in 1993.
Human beings were monkeys.
We were monkeys with a o railroad
system.
Had a language and cars.
What you can do,
go to the encyclopedia and look it up.
Yeah,
we're so much fucking smarter now,
but it was interesting because after I'd
met her,
she was.
She was getting on in age and she's
still alive.
She's born in Nineteen,
26,
so to to be able to look back and see
her.
After I met her then I watched the Dick
Van Dyke show and I got to look back and
see her on what was like for a lot of
people that were alive at the time.
That was an iconic program and so I was
like,
oh,
now I know why these older people that
were on the set were like freaked out
that she was like,
Jesus Christ would be weird to be on
television if you were born and lived
before television was even invented
often.
Yeah,
I mean I know you looked it up before
and it was invented way back before it
was common.
Right.
But still it wasn't common until the
fifties.
Yeah.
And people that they barely had enough
money to buy one of those gigantic
furniture things you would roll into
your living room and occupy a good solid
10 square feet of space.
Um,
see if you could brian see if you could
find the Dick van dyke show,
like a highlight or clip of a show on,
um,
on,
uh,
Youtube.
Yeah,
she's a very nice lady though.
She was very funny too.
She still does.
I'm sure she's still alive.
But um,
like I said,
man,
it ain't easy for everybody.
Shares a lot.
A lot of people that don't get a shot.
The thing about acting that's kind of
fucked is a,
how many people out there would be
awesome at it if they apply themselves.
There's a lot of friends that we have
that don't act at all.
But if they really decided to be bad ass
actors,
that would be incredible at it.
Right.
And I think there's a lot of people that
work,
like a lot of regular jobs that they
decided to apply themselves to it.
They could be awesome at actress,
but yeah,
but the thing is like,
like getting,
getting like discovered like the,
the sheer numbers of fucking people that
are coming here.
Like what do you think?
Like if a role comes out for a movie,
like let's just say the full charge
writes a movie.
Yeah,
for you.
I feel action sort of hand to hand
combat specialists.
Let's go with the mat fold.
Try to Pakistan to fucking rectify some
shit.
Some shit.
Some people that are just,
they can't.
They don't know how to make a deal work
smoothly and sometimes you got to knock
a little and you've got to be able to do
both and that's what the full charges
here for.
I'm like Seagal.
It's like the movie tells you what I am.
Matt.
False.
Ron is the full charge and I just knock
out terrorists and I fucking saved the
world constantly.
I see that being on Spike TV in the fall
of 2016.
If we are our cards correctly,
we gave them a little taste by talking
about it here on the podcast.
Let the pitch meetings begin.
Let's watch this.
God Damn Mary Tyler Moore,
Mary Tyler Moore.
Good craziness.
Death of the party.
Just the way people pretended that
people were back then is weird.
Sleep in the same bed.
At least look at this.
Yeah,
that is pretty sexy.
No,
they don't man.
Look at the separation between the two
beds.
Right?
Oh my God.
I'm so sad now.
She's so hot and she's right there and
he has to sleep in the next bed.
That is bullshit,
but doing it from behind was with a lot
more popular back then because you had
that extra gap so yours is always
probably just leaned over the bed.
I don't think people really live like
that,
dude.
No they didn't.
It was TV,
TV,
TV rules.
They would never show.
They would see gives.
If you have people sleep in the same
band together,
you're implying that they're fucking.
Don't want to imply that this is
wholesome.
Dick Van Dyke is father knows best.
Just wants to play golf.
That's it.
Yeah.
He's just trying to sneak out and play
some golf.
Ain't trying to fuck his wife.
What he's doing right now is running
from the prison warden who tells him
that he can't do what he wants to do
with his life.
Sushi master.
God,
she's so hot though.
They cute.
Cute prison warden.
Look,
she wakes up with her hair.
Perfect.
Amazing.
She's got full war paint on and her hair
is perfect.
Look at that.
This is so weird,
man.
Because this is like a time capsule.
Oh boy.
Curse word back then.
This shit hadn't been done before.
We're watching some shit that like
what happened to got the spark plugs.
I was so proud.
I dressed by shape and AIPAC and got out
without waking you up and it was so
brad,
you had to come back and tell him,
Hey,
I forgot my keys and my money.
I'm sorry.
Oh yeah.
I'm sorry honey.
Look what?
She wears the bed.
I closed the door and when the money.
Honey,
I'm sorry.
Get over it.
So you still mad at me from last night?
No,
I'm not mad now and I wasn't mad last
night.
This would be a weird sort of a piece.
If someone decided to recreate this
show,
the exact sort of inflection,
right?
It's not,
I'm inconsiderate.
I mean if I'm anything but I did
consider a guilty.
I'm guilty of is talking to you right
now where there are three guys waiting
for me to tee off,
darling.
Oh,
did you get it?
I get it.
You get that one,
get that.
Can you imagine that?
At one point in time that was cutting
edge.
That was,
I was like saying go fuck off.
It's really weird watching old shit like
that.
Did you see?
Uh,
I was listening to Opie and Anthony and
they were talking about,
uh,
the house from the future that they used
to have,
whereas like in the future we're going
to have and they,
and they were showing them how much
similarities of what they guessed the
house of the future was what show was it
on the,
they had it,
it was back back in the day.
It used to be at epcot or it used to be
at Disneyland.
It used to be this building.
You walked in and was like,
in that future,
this is what it tells.
So it was a ride,
kind of.
It's like a standing right.
If I remember,
I'll show you.
They have the video online,
but the guests,
things like,
you know,
a microwave,
microwave,
online shopping,
they guessed.
Really?
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
Wow.
So,
so is there anything in there that the,
that we don't have Brian?
Uh,
yeah,
there,
there was a lot of spinning
the wheels but in young Mr.
I can't think of an old charge
enterprises,
but I'm going to do is I'm going to go,
I'm going to watch old shit with the
predicted the future.
Find out what happened and what didn't
and then pick up the pieces.
Is there a mailbox that blows you gail?
Cancel all my appointments.
Yeah.
Here's the,
here's some photos from what it used to
be.
Oh Wow.
So what was this,
when was this created?
What year?
I believe it was the 19 five.
Nineteen 57 to 1967.
And it was called,
believe it or not,
the Monsanto House.
Monsanto.
You fucking devil.
And uh,
that's hilarious.
How's the view?
Yeah,
but I,
I remember going to,
I think it was at epcot when I went to
it.
Wow.
And I'll find a video.
The video is actually,
there's a house that was a.
I wonder if it's still up.
There was a house in the Hollywood hills
somewhere that I saw.
Not In person ever,
but I've seen it in photos that looks
like a Ufo.
Have you ever seen?
I've never seen that.
Now I'm gonna find it on Google,
the flying saucer house.
James [inaudible] fired or Brian Flying
saucer house.
I think it's in Holland when,
but uh,
it's so wicked.
It's a house though that once you lived
in it for a little while,
he'd be like,
all right,
this is ridiculous.
Look at it.
How dope is that?
Right.
The encounter at lax,
that restaurant.
But this is someone's fucking house,
man.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Someone's chilling in that house.
Okay.
I take it back.
That's,
that's Uber Dope.
I would love to learn that.
It's like living in this space needle.
Look at this photo.
Wow.
Let's try it to see if he can pull that
one up so that you stream people can see
it.
This fucking house is radical.
You might even survive an earthquake or
an avalanche or something in that.
You would be worshiped by Star Trek and
star wars geeks and where's this at
Hollywood hills or somewhere in
Hollywood.
I'm John Lottner by John Lautner.
He's the guy who created it.
I'm wondering when this was built.
Oh,
okay.
It was a construction back in 1960,
but it was recently renovated.
Huh?
God,
that's fucking wicked house is
incredible.
They're so cocky though,
like local people do in California,
they take a hill in a place where the
ground moves all the fucking time and
they just stick a big spike right down
the middle and put a circle on it.
Says they'll stay here.
I can't believe no one lives in the
death star or whatever.
No one's recreated that they'll live in.
You just put out a fucking awesome
message into someone's gonna.
Run with that.
Make sure you finish it guys.
You don't want to leave any weak spots.
Now should.
He didn't make it full size,
full charge where they would have to to
satisfy me starting in space.
What are we doing?
I don't know.
That's for the nerds to figure out.
Get on at boys.
Seriously though.
If you're a single guy.
Full charge.
Yeah.
No,
you are and you're looking to be sly and
you look at it.
Really impressive Gal with where you
live in two dozen roses,
two dozen roses at the fucking the Ufo
House.
You bring her up to the Ufo House.
This chick thinks you're balling.
I want you to look at a view my friend.
Look at the fucking view from this
place.
That's what that shit.
That's so awesome.
Come on.
That view of Los Angeles at night is a
really crazy view.
Have you ever seen that view,
Brian?
You ever been on top of Doheny?
Yeah.
I would go up and down.
Look at that shit.
It never disappoints.
Men who would look at that fucking view.
That's insane.
That that is an incredible picture.
This house is so weird because it's just
surrounded by glass because of is a Ufo
theme.
Yeah.
It's kind of amazing that there's not
more of these like really weird freaky
houses in Hollywood.
You would think there would be a lot of
like weird,
unusual.
I guess by the time you can afford a
house you've kind like got rid of all
those crazy ideas about living in a
fucking.
Yeah,
I think so.
And like if you do come up with a crazy
plan for it.
If you're an architect and you've got to
find somebody who's crazy enough to do
it,
but he also wants to find like the
homeowner's association has to agree.
That's a big deal in California,
right?
They say no to a lot of stuff,
don't they?
It's a big deal everywhere.
I was reading about this woman who's
getting in trouble because she was a in
Florida,
in Miami.
She's growing vegetables in her front
lawn because that's the only part of her
house that gets hit by son.
So she's grown her vegetables there.
She's been doing it for like 17 years
and they trying to get her to stop,
like,
like the city is coming in and telling a
lady stopped growing healthy food on her
property.
It's fucking vegetables to have
invested.
Like someone's going to walk by.
They're going to be offended if they see
a tomato plant.
Yeah.
Like what the fuck kind of craziness is
that?
Why are you telling people they can't
have food up?
What could grow?
Anything else?
Yes,
she can and she's allowed to grow
flowers.
She grow fucking pine trees.
Probably thinks she wants.
Can't grow marijuana.
Full charge.
That shit's illegal,
dude.
That shit is illegal.
Especially down in that country.
Known as Florida.
Oh,
Florida.
Not America or California,
right?
This guy made star Trek House.
Whole entire house is just like the
ship.
Do you hear that?
That's the sound of a million panties.
Getting wet.
That's fucking dope.
Look at this guy's house.
Look at his fucking.
Even as fireplace.
He did up his fireplace.
You ever seen that documentary?
Trekkies?
Yes.
Long time ago.
Dedicating their lives.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that just get
obsessed with anything,
whether it's world of warcraft being a
trekkie,
being a furry and trails,
chem trails,
anything.
Do you ever see that?
All of a sudden that live sketch where
William Shatner is at a a trekkie
convention?
Oh No.
He just tells off all the trekkies John
Lewis.
He's like,
yeah,
you're 30.
You ever kissed a girl?
He's like,
you took something fun.
I did in the sixties and turn it into a
colossal waste of time.
How rude.
Yeah.
I wonder how the trekkies felt about
that trade.
It was one of the first like trekkie
things on tv,
you know,
so they probably appreciated that they
were being recognized.
Yeah.
It's kind of an interesting,
like what shows
take off with that.
It's not like star trek went on forever.
It went on for a few years.
I think it was five.
Was it five years?
I don't think it was that many.
I think it was more like three.
Let's say Star Trek was a great fucking
Cheryl.
I'll tell you that,
but it's amazing that like,
okay,
here's another perfect example.
The,
uh,
the fucking rocky hard midnight show,
whatever it is,
when they do the rocky horror picture
show at midnight ones and they have
these people get up and they sing along
to the music they were,
they throw rice,
they wear the clothes that everybody's
wearing and in the music and the
musical,
they still do it at the new art,
like once a month,
once a week.
How's that one take off?
Like why that would is,
what is it about the rocky horror
picture show that makes everyone want to
get together and watch it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again.
Have these midnight screenings and
everybody loves it and they dress up and
it's,
it's a community.
Yeah.
But if forms over this one fucking weird
movie,
it's all such a fucking perfect storm of
events that comes out at the right time,
right?
When people notice it doesn't hurt.
The movie is fucking bad ass.
One time viewing is a bad ass movie.
It's very good.
Rocky horror picture show is a very good
movie.
I love that movie.
Especially at the time.
I don't know how it holds up to get
today might be a little absurd.
Knowing all the rocky horror picture
show shit behind it.
That's one thing I'm very aware of but
don't know anything about.
So I've never seen it and I don't.
Yeah.
It's because it's,
it's also a time capsule.
I should probably see it again to four.
I recommend it because,
you know,
I've,
I've watched um,
the uh,
altered states moving that uh,
William hurt movie about isolation
tanks.
I watched it and I thought it was the
most amazing movie ever got me into
isolation.
Tanks got me researching and eventually
got me to own one.
So it was like a pivotal moment in my
life seeing that movie and I remember it
being very good.
High wants to
dog shit is terrible.
I've barely gotten.
Not only that,
I tried to talk Mrs Rogan into
Washington with me.
Watch this shit with me for five
minutes.
She was like,
Oh fuck,
are you so bad man,
it's missing so much that makes a movie
good.
And then you don't get to pick the movie
again for another three or four choices.
Do you know,
talking about full trust me.
Yeah.
It's weird how movies don't fucking hold
up.
It's a lot of them don't,
but a lot of them do,
but it's so strange.
Like watch the Godfather.
It's perfect.
It's God damn perfect gem.
It's.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Everything is great about it.
I can't imagine goodfellas ever been
bad.
It's impossible.
It's a perfect movie.
There's movies that are just so good.
It doesn't matter if someone else
achieved great heights as well.
Yeah,
that movie's still gonna stand no matter
what era it's shown in.
Especially in consideration between like
what technology was available to shoot a
movie like that then as it was when it
was,
what's available today.
You know,
it's good when not even Martin Scorsese
can top it.
He's the one that did it.
There you go.
One flew over the cuckoo's nest holds
up.
Fuck.
Yeah,
it does.
That's a timeless.
A theme,
right?
The Nicholson was I bad motherfucker
when he was young.
You know,
people remember Nicholas who's sitting
in front of court at the Lakers game and
when he pretended to be a wolf and they
remembered some stupid shit,
Nicholson,
but go back to China town watch
Nicholson and China town.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Dude.
China.
China town is another one.
Chinatown holds up.
He was so bad.
He was so good in Chinatown.
We talked about it last time I was here.
10 signs point to China,
I swear to Christ,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How did we get to them as a major talent
to separate and isn't crazy
conspiracies.
Crazy.
Full charge.
I don't even know how it happened.
I Nicholson was the original full charge
Chinese secret.
He did a lot of fucking great movies to
men and you know,
he's still got it.
Like that movie,
the departed.
He was still growing.
He's still great.
He's just.
And he has like moved seamlessly from
young hot guides,
old,
creepy guy seamlessly.
Like there was a show recently,
you know,
that fast and loud.
You know,
that show I don't think I do enough.
Fast and loud is those guys,
uh,
in Dallas,
they have cars and they have a,
it's called gas monkey garage place and
they take cars,
they buy them,
they fix them up and they resell them,
sell them at auction and sell them to
collectors.
It's funny show.
I enjoy it.
Um,
and fuck.
What was my point?
Nicholson?
Fuck God.
Oh,
that's what it is.
Okay.
I'm sorry I got distracted because it's
a really good shot.
Right?
They did an episode with Burt Reynolds.
That's where I got distracted.
They were redoing a trans am and the
Trans am was the burt reynolds firebird
from smokey and the bandit car.
Perfect car for like when you're in high
school,
like during those,
that those days when smoking the band
was on.
That was the fucking car.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
It's a firebird.
Trans Am.
Woo.
The flames on the hood and Shit.
I mean it was an amazing car for like
several years because of burt reynolds.
But dude,
burt reynolds is fucked.
Like he's hunched over.
They had him in there signing.
He's hunched over.
Great Hair,
incredible hair.
It's ridiculous.
He's his face.
Has been operated on way too many times.
Yeah,
it's strange and he's got sunglasses on
and you remember him from like
deliverance.
This virile,
strong,
like dangerous looking dude who had just
gotten done playing football
essentially.
You know,
he'd played football in college in
Florida and went from there into the
movies.
He was a bad mother fucker,
but you,
he couldn't make that transition.
Now you can become the old guy.
The spread couldn't make the spread.
Couldn't be himself throughout the ages.
Where is Nicholson?
The hair started falling out.
No toupee.
Just show up to her award.
Shows his hair all fucked up.
He big balls by.
Doesn't give a shit.
He was always a freaking,
oh,
he's an artist so he can kinda roll with
it.
He rolled with everything rolled with
getting fat.
He just kept getting fatter and fatter
and fatter.
And he was in that movie with a share
where he played the devil or something
like that.
You remember that movie?
She devils or something?
There were witches.
Witches of Eastwick.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
And he was already like fat and creepy.
Then you know,
he like made this transition seamlessly,
right?
So him and Burt Reynolds probably very
similar in age,
but he looks great and you look at Logan
Nicholson,
he looks great.
He looks like an old guy and he was at
the game the other day or floyd
mayweather fight and he's eating popcorn
while they're interviewing him.
Chewing Pie.
You're not stopping for your camera if
you want to talk to Jack while he's
fucking watching the fights.
He's going to eat popcorn,
but you don't feel sad for him,
right?
You see burt reynolds,
you're like,
Jesus Christ.
Look at this poor guy like his bond.
He's all hunched over.
He looks like he weighs maybe 100
pounds.
I'm not even kidding.
He's got the wig on.
He's got his face is drawn from surgery
and weird and shiny.
He's gotten.
This is kind of spark.
He's got no life.
It's.
It's depressing.
It's depressing when you consider like
how funny he was.
If you go watch smokey and the bandit,
it's another time capsule,
but it's hard to see.
It's hard.
He doesn't even look like that now.
Man.
You know what's weird about smokey and
the bandit?
I watched it a couple of years ago.
There's no.
There's no one under 30 in that movie.
Right,
and they don't do that movies anymore.
It's all like young hot shots smoking
the band.
It was fun,
man.
The only young people that hadn't smoked
in the band,
it was people that almost got hit by
cars on the baseball field when when
they jumped and started driving on a
baseball field.
How great is the Jackie gleason in that
movie?
Burt Reynolds had that.
He was great.
Jackie.
Jackie gleason was awesome.
Moving.
What was that one?
I'm trying.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but I remember this one.
Burt Reynolds movie.
I think it was domino.
Was that what it's called?
Hold on.
Raynald's.
That's a weird way to spell it.
Real good.
That sexy motherfucker Joe,
look at at.
He made the hairy chest sexy.
Oh,
hold me back.
So a lot of God damn movies.
Stick Sharkey's machine.
That was it.
Do you remember that moving out or burt
reynolds?
It was a good movie man bird.
It was a cop movie and at the time I
fucking loved it.
It only has a six point two.
I bet if I watched today,
I think it sucks,
but I was 14 years old and burt reynolds
played a bad ass in this,
uh,
who's in narcotics cop and Atlanta to
mobile device after a botched bust and
the depths of this lowly division while
investigating a high dollar prostitution
ring.
Sharkey stumbled across a mob murder
with government
ties.
Isn't it funny when you read like crazy
are super overly dramatic movie read
like the description you're like,
what kind of life is this?
All this keeps happening to you.
Starkey stumbled,
shockey stumbles across a mob.
Murder with government ties and responds
by assembling is downtrodden fellow
investigators,
Sharkey's machine to find the leaders
and bring them to justice.
Meanwhile,
most cops are bored out of their fucking
minds is sitting around the office.
No evidence,
no nothing.
I bet it's terrible if I watch it today,
but Goddamn,
I liked it at the time when I was 14.
Did he ever go mustache lists as he
mustache?
Listen,
Boogie nights?
I don't think he.
I don't know.
He,
he loved the mustache man.
He wore it a lot.
Do you have tape over your Webcam?
Yeah,
you don't.
I don't want people seeing me being
tired of the NSA.
Oh,
you know what it was,
but I actually had a tape that they put
over this thing from filming the show.
They wanted to cover my apple logo and I
had an extra piece and I put it over the
camera as a goof and then just left it
there.
I met this girl the other day that had a
camera or on me and on her phone she had
tape on the front end tape on the back
like a crazy person because she's like
an FBI agent.
Well now people are afraid of the NSA,
the NSA,
tuning into your laptop.
If you look through a million hours of
me,
you're going to see in me in front of
the computer and then 10 percent of
those times I'll be beating off.
That's you going to say.
So if you need to see that.
Still not a crime through that thing,
but like why would anybody want to go
through that data?
What are you trying to prove?
I just tell you,
this has been documented for some people
though.
It's dangerous as I find out that you
beat off.
Like if you found out the Colin Powell
was an obsessive like foot fetish.
It would change the way I thought about
him.
That's his move.
He loved like watching a video.
Very specific.
One girl's licking your balls while the
other one you're coming on our feet
right now.
That would change the way I thought
about him and I would question his
ability to lead the military style even
though it's irrational for me to think
that.
Yeah.
If you found out that he was really into
transgender porn,
that was his big thing.
You would.
You would not trust them when it comes
to decision making.
Yeah,
because I mean meanwhile there's no
other indications.
He's exactly the same person as when he
was like the most awesome general ever.
His resumes the exact same.
Just find all this training.
Porn shaped.
What if it gets out to the news?
People find out how we enjoy this
pleasure.
Was that slice of pain trans transgender
with a girl.
It's pretty sweet.
Um,
what does that mean girl to a boy,
meaning like a girl that has like boobs
and hectic but it dick and it's fucking
a normal girl that's hot you that,
you watch that,
watch that because it's like you take
the guy who you don't really want to see
anyways and you give them boobs and make
them look like a girl.
It doesn't affect Brian's reputation
when he says something like that.
It doesn't have a reputation.
Reputation is that.
That's the best aspect of his
personality,
his curiosity and his willingness to
hang his neck out there,
but we don't want them leaving
the military at the same time.
It's like instead of having to look at a
hairy dude or some ugly dude.
No,
I see your logic.
Have you tried it?
No,
it doesn't work with me.
I limit myself to a,
to.
I don't want to watch that.
I'm scared.
I'll like it because then it'll be all I
watch and now I'm Colin Powell.
I think personally when you start
getting into weird freaky shit,
like if you're only into like someone
coming on feet or something like that,
you need to stop beating off for a
couple months.
Like maybe you've talked yourself into
some weird box where every girl has to
have a dick and you know everybody's
feed up to have red nails,
just no fucking red nail Polish.
You'll fight your search message boards
for the Red Nail Polish fetish jerking
off forum and everyone agrees with these
assholes.
Black Goth toads who wants to see that
and you find the red nail Polish,
but still not good enough.
You've got to find the perfect.
There's always gonna be people to take
anything,
whether it's a conversation,
whether it's a relationship or whether
it's star trek and take things to a bad
place.
They take a good thing and they put it
in a bad place.
That's why porn gets such a God damn
terrible reputation is because.
Yeah,
there is a few dudes who beat off a wee
bit.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
me too much,
but there's also people that use it so
that you don't have to date people.
They don't really want to date just to
get some sex.
They just see it and they,
you know,
they didn't create it.
They don't feel totally responsible for
just watching it and downloading it and
then they beat off and then they go
about their day full charge being
trapped like poor Dick Van Dyke,
Dick Van Dyke who had to sleep in a
different bed,
wasn't allowed to beat off them,
couldn't even go fishing back then.
They thought Satan would come and steal
you and your sleep if you beat off.
Yeah,
they did.
They didn't know how it got labeled a
homosexual thing.
Beat off and be masturbating.
Beat off and be gay.
Well,
it should be.
I mean,
you're a man fucking a man.
You have a dick in your hand.
What are you doing?
You're doing gay shit.
You're fucking a man's hand up there.
You.
Oh,
I quit fucking Weirdo.
Weirdo.
Fucking your own.
I don't believe in gay sex except my own
hand.
My both my hands are gay as fuck.
Yeah,
I right to way more guy left hands gay
and my right hand's getting.
Fortunately they're only gay from my
Dick.
Monogamous lucked out on that one.
Not there's anything wrong with being
gay,
but it seems like you guys carried more
weight than we do.
We carry,
carry a greater societal burden.
Wouldn't not from people like me but
from people who judge.
Yup.
So in that case,
I'm glad my Dick is the only thing that
my hands are attracted to.
You have less to deal with.
Gay Hands are called Jazz hands,
right?
No jazz hands.
Trying to put a little extra energy and
something that really sucks.
You know,
something that's really not that good or
you're trying to downplay something that
is unbelievably super awesome data.
Like if you're standing there in front
of a movie waiting for three years and
you have the opening night tickets,
those are legit jazz hands.
You know when you're waiting for the
hobbit.
Desolation of smoke to come out waiting
in line.
Do you remember when the fucking Harry
Potter novels were coming out and people
were making videos of them running by
and giving away the ending?
Oh,
no,
no.
Yeah,
God,
those guys were cons.
It would have been great if the video
ended with somebody just full line
citing the guy on the bike just knocking
them down,
kicking his ass and all the fucking
Harry Potter dorks join in.
It was funny.
Beaten with brooms.
Imagine man.
Just wanting to steal joy is one,
a steel mystery from people.
There's always somebody and that was
bad.
I mean,
you know,
I guess the Internet was still around
then.
I don't know what kind of spoilers you
would get because social media wasn't as
strong like twitter and facebook and all
that stuff,
so I bet it was probably harder to find
out accidentally with the end of a book
was you had to search for a spoiler.
Yeah.
Basically back then you got to really go
looking or you had to get stuck next to
some asshole who won't stop talking
about it and you're like,
I don't want to know.
No,
it doesn't matter.
You're still enjoy it.
Listen,
he goes into the like,
why are you still telling me this?
I've been working all week and when I'm
done,
I want to watch Harry Potter.
God
damaged.
I had a guy do that to me.
Once I got that I really respected and
was so brutal.
I couldn't believe my opinion of him
changed.
So I always use a famous guy.
He's telling me this really fucking
boring version of that.
Um,
what is the,
the,
the.
I drink your milkshake moving.
Oh,
there will be blood.
There will be blood.
Yeah.
And he's telling me about the opening
scene.
He's describing the scene.
I'm like,
please stop.
Please stop.
I'm going to see this movie.
It doesn't matter.
So you still enjoy it.
I still enjoy.
I'll feel it.
Enjoy it.
You're telling me what's happening and
he wouldn't stop.
I literally had to walk away.
I go,
Jesus fucking Christ.
And I had A.
I had to leave.
He was insisting on letting,
not just me,
but other people around me know exactly
what happened in this opening scene.
I'm like,
fucking quizzes.
Daniel Day Lewis was doing.
Dude,
I told you don't talk about me and
Daniel,
if I have a protein shake to think he
does everything perfectly.
I would never criticize him.
Have you guys seen those pants that the
young kids are wearing nowadays that
looks like these young kids?
Kids.
It's where it looks like you have like
poopy drawers almost.
Where it's like it's not droopy pants
here.
Here's a video like fever,
like wearing them where it almost looks
like,
like the crutches down way far like by
your knees and it almost.
Oh,
hold on.
Like hammering and almost looks kind of
like hammer pants.
What?
This.
Okay.
So they're skinny,
but bagging the crotch.
Like the crotch goes down to you about
your knees.
You look like kind of like a penguin or
you better not be checking leg kicks.
Tell you that and see how the pot book
that's coming out of his van.
This is from yesterday.
He's getting in trouble.
Exclusive.
Yeah.
They were like,
police were telling me it can't hotbox
with his van.
Why is he driving in a van?
Is that how he gets around?
I guess so.
He brings his crew with him.
That's how you bring a crew.
Yeah.
You have to advantage when everybody
traveled together.
He's got immense crew.
You know when you're a legit super duper
star,
you gathering immense crew like he has.
I'd love to have a crew.
I think the full charge crew needs a
special name,
like the volts to charge heads or the.
Yeah,
the the volts.
The amps.
Amperage ever readies like that
Duracell's duracell group.
I've seen people wear these pants all
the time and they hit me in a like a
like a,
like a gross out.
Oh,
here they are because they are.
They're like hammer pants and I'm not
shocked this shit right now.
I am not shocked.
Human beings are begging for the aliens
to fucking wipe us out.
Begging with every new fashion choice.
With every new video we make.
Seemed like it was getting pretty normal
there for awhile.
Incorrect.
Full charge.
Very sweat of paying attention.
Fella.
It's been downhill since the fucking
bell bottom.
We accepted the bell bottom and it was a
slide my friend,
a slide.
I think I'm going to go to track suits
and fanny packs.
I'll do it.
I think I'm going to commit.
I'm for the tracks.
One track suit and fanny pack is my new
look for life.
I think my body will appreciate it.
It's very light and relaxing.
Let's find some good tracksuits Brian,
and change that to our new wardrobe.
Show you what?
The ones that I want to live in
California.
Man.
I don't need to wear thermals and shit.
I don't need layers of goose down.
I can get by with a track suit and a
fanny pack.
I want to be part.
I want to be part of your crew.
I don't feel like it started my own
tracks.
What kind of sneakers should we were?
We definitely got to wear pumas or
Adidas,
whatever,
whatever the whatever the track suit is.
Here's the shoes.
That was a six dozer.
Good.
That's good.
That's a good choice.
That's a comfortable shoe to.
Yep,
and if you're wearing like a blue track
suit with some white stripes,
that'll fit nicely.
If we learned anything from fat James,
it's track suits and a six.
No doubt about it.
Rest in peace.
Fred James.
Yeah,
track suits and a six.
I haven't had a track suit since I was
probably 19.
Was the last time you had an actual
legit tracks?
I got one when I was like 28 because one
of the.
I was going out with this girl.
I wanted to try to pull it off like
we're talking about now.
Yeah,
she worked at a echo,
you know that,
that Mark Echo that clothing line.
She worked there and I'm like,
give me one of these tracksuits.
And I tried it for like a week and I
just couldn't keep it up,
you know,
track suit.
I couldn't commit,
couldn't put it that way.
I didn't have a crew.
Yeah.
These weren't ready yet to get to have
some other venue that also work so
everybody doesn't give a fuck together,
you know,
because it's just you on your own out
there in the wilderness of life,
being judged by your fashion choices
where to fucking tracksuit.
And you see a girl outside of a place
where a girl,
if you were dressed like this,
you'd be like,
Oh,
oh,
your mat,
full tron,
stand up comedian.
But she sees
you and while you're wearing a track
suit,
just like being casual,
and I like dressing like a moron is that
they don't buy that anymore or they
don't buy it.
Is it a moral thing or is it a
comfortable thing?
Are we the morons full charge?
I know I'm the moron with our zippers to
get our dicks trapped in our belts when
we could just have a simple drawstring,
easy access.
We got to start smoking cigars to to
let's do it.
So little,
little back,
little bit of organized crime.
Bruce Lee,
Bruce Lee owned that type of track suit.
The same way Hitler on the mustache.
You can't wear that without people
thinking that you bruce.
I said Bruce,
many more people than I see like this
one.
Nothing.
You could wear that no problem.
But that game of death one,
now Bruce Lee owns that.
That's,
that's his.
You can't wear that.
You can't wear a yellow jumpsuit.
It'd be embarrassing to wear a jumpsuit
and like a break dance competition
breaks out and then you got nothing.
You get nothing.
You're just kind of inching away
quietly.
Bruce Lee,
that,
that yellow track suit.
If you wear that,
people go,
Yo,
what's up bruce?
They'll immediately go to that.
That tracks who is off limits.
If you have a track suit,
you better learn a skill and that had
better be karate,
breakdancing or account numbers and now
that I'm thinking about it,
is there one actor more synonymous with
a very specific type of jumpsuit?
Then Bruce Lee?
No,
I mean unless you count ll cool j,
which you can't,
but they can't because he owned that
yellow jumpsuit and the game of their
eyes so hard that to this day,
the only time you see people wearing
them is when they're wearing it for a
bruce Lee costume.
Right?
A key owns that fucking yellow jumpsuit.
There's never been a time like that
where someone has just a really standard
type of athletic apparel that is so
common to them that when you see it,
all you think about is them fanny pack.
Hey,
a fanny pack,
when you have an ass like that,
no one sees anything other than your
ass.
That fanny pack is only examined by
people online.
If you were there in front of her,
it would be like a mirage.
You wouldn't be able to sit and you'd
see her hips to asset ratio is
incredible.
I think that it's a real.
She's ridiculous.
Ridiculously hot.
I forget what we're talking about now.
Jack Nicholson,
burt reynolds was burt rental truck.
It was.
When you see a guy like burt reynolds
that's like had all that plastic surgery
and really hurting right now.
No one's won the plastic surgery game
yet.
Have they?
Well,
here's what's really crazy.
You know,
it was the same age as him,
so investors,
stallone [inaudible] that crazy.
Fuck.
That looks like he's 30 years old,
right?
I mean its face doesn't it?
But his body is ridiculous.
He's fucking shredded.
What Sylvester do and just hair dye.
I mean he's definitely doing that.
He's eating babies but to sylvester have
any plastic surgery hormones.
Yeah,
I'm sure he has.
He said he's an actor the most.
By the time they get to be like that
age,
especially with superstar blockbuster
type dudes that keep the hair the same
color.
I've had a little bit of something done.
Yeah,
no,
just a little tuck here.
A little botox there.
They get that weird shiny skin that
doesn't move and when they do this it
doesn't work.
Right.
So it's like.
So then he can't even act.
It's like shiny.
Can't even be surprised.
You know?
You can be surprised you're in a movie.
Somebody hired your old crazy ass.
He poisoned skin.
Frozen.
Fucking paralyzed skin because you think
that looks better.
Bruce Willis kept it real.
Still working.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those guys.
Right.
And then stand up comedy to a lot of
those guys.
Like a George Carlin.
Perfect example.
George Carlin just kept being George
Carlin through being a young guy to be
in an old curmudgeon and old,
like scholarly curmudgeon,
breaking down the.
You know,
the,
the funny shit about the world became
stayed the same guy.
Yeah.
Something happened to some people
though,
man,
where they just can't do that.
If something happens to some people,
they just can't accept it.
They got to cut their face.
Yeah.
Not a lot of comics doing this.
The surgery.
Right.
What if it became like shown on paper
that duck lips like every punchline.
Ten percent,
but it probably does
slips.
He Does Punch Lips.
I say a punchline.
Lips.
It does it like on purpose.
Like tell joking
and he's got his face cut too.
He's got that scar.
Yeah.
But that scar is an accident.
And you're right though,
because that's car king from a laser
surgery.
He was trying to get as hair removed
from his face and they burned his face.
Bronies fucking every fucking Harry.
And He shaves his face.
He gets stubble like an hour later and
it's all the way up to his cheeks.
So you had it.
He was trying to get it lasered.
They boxed them.
I wonder if he got paid for that.
Did you get paid for that?
I don't know.
But you might have just done it again on
his eyebrows and that's why he wears the
hat down like this and glasses.
I hope he doesn't.
He doesn't need to do that.
He's brody,
she didn't give them love for food
eyebrows or something.
Doesn't really laser lasered eyebrows
and the they physically much.
It's something that lasts up to like,
I think he said six months or something
like
lasered.
Yeah.
Well the laser,
it,
it'll,
it'll kill like a lot of your eyebrow
hairs for a long time.
Like a lot of girls get on there.
I go down,
the Hoo Ha and they get it lasered down.
Right?
It gets a tattoo though.
It's not permanent tattoo,
but it's when it goes away in like six
months.
What are you talking about?
He has eyebrows tattooed.
That's why I shouldn't be talking about
why while you're talking about that.
We talked about on an ice house cause he
already talked to you yet.
He's so crazy.
He would.
The hair chronicles.
He was fucking unbelievably funny.
The last time he was on here.
Everybody's talking about it.
Then one of the funniest podcast I've
ever done with him without a doubt.
So cool.
He's got the TV show because he like.
I
don't know if you remember,
like when he showed up in La in the late
nineties,
everyone was going fucking ape shit for
him.
Like on the,
on the comic circuit.
Well,
I know comics have always respected him.
He's always been a guy that we stan hope
and I had him to the opening warmup
stuff.